there's a lot of new information in the
waukesha attack first of all as i've
been covering as andy know covered and
now many other outlets have covered the
new york post and the daily mail among
many others
the perpetrator had
threatened white people on social media
he had posted black nationalist memes
he had expressed support for black lives
matter
and there's a lot of other information
from the police reports about how he was
slowly driving up through the parade to
towards the parade slow enough that a
cop was able to bang on the hood and
then walk around and bang on the door
and tell him to stop
so this was not a pursuit
this was an intentional act and that's
exactly what this man was charged with
but now there's new information
the man in question
brooks
apparently had threatened to blow up a
casino in the past now why is it that
the media has come out and said it was
an accident nbc
many activists on msnbc a man said it
was it was an accident what are they
calling it across the internet a crash
a crash
strangely i am shocked to say this debra
messing of all people had a tweet where
said it was not an accident it was
intentional it was the waukesha massacre
so we're gonna get into all this and
we're gonna break down the media lies
and what's going on and we also have big
news in the ahmed arbory case all three
men were convicted of murder in the
death of ahmed arbory now on the law
seems like it was correct but there are
some serious problems i think we need to
talk about
uh as it pertains to
citizens arrest and self-defense and i
just want to stress man
the neighbor who was filming it they
charged him with murder too yikes man he
was just following behind filming what
was going on but hey
you are party to a group that surrounds
a guy
and the death occurs if the citizen's
arrest was not justified you're all
going to get charged now i'm not the
expert on self-defense so we brought in
the expert on self-defense and you bro
andrew branca branca is it which one is
it
i've been saying it wrong the entire
time either way is fine so uh tell us
what you do you've been on the show
before yes i'm an attorney i do uh use
of force law self-defense law
that's all i do i don't have a
generalized criminal defense practice
i've been doing that
this year is 30 years now doing nothing
but use of force law in all 50 states uh
to my knowledge i'm the only attorney in
the country with that explicit focus
strictly on use of force law certainly
for that duration of time so getting
into uh the ahmed arbory stuff as well
as the right now stuff is going to be
really interesting
i watched
every minute of the written house trial
in much of the arbre trial as well so i
have definitely uh strongly held
opinions on both those cases and it's
crazy to me um not to take up too much
time but the arbory case people really
don't seem to know anything about this
even conservatives right now they're
getting it wrong but we'll get into all
that sure and we also have another
individual who was an expert on many
subjects who was uh you worked in
intelligence as well as just you're on
the beat you know the news we got jack
basobic you see i'm i'm confused tim
you're talking about you know you're
telling me that there's some
driver of this this suv and yet i've
been reading the media and it tells you
know the new york times says the suv
just drove through the parade by itself
it doesn't say anything about a driver
i'm looking on the wikipedia page it
just says an suv drove through it
doesn't say anything about it you're
talking about all this other stuff which
transformer is the red suv
the board escape transfer
it's not optimus prime is it no no he's
a he's a tractor trailer or something
yeah oh a tractor trailer yeah so it
couldn't be optimus prime would you say
it was megatron it was probably megatron
did it
obviously a decepticon yeah the media
saying an suv did it oh isn't it amazing
how they do that passive voice nothing
like it yeah well they're trying to
cover all this up so
uh i think what's going on it's very
clear this is a disinformation campaign
this was something that had been started
very early and that's the way all good
disinformation campaigns start you get
the lie out as fast as possible who was
the source
who was the source from the local police
that went to the the national media and
said that he was fleeing from a knife
fight ask that question
and you'll get your answer he was sealed
in his car i don't know it was if the
guy with the knife wasn't in his car
with him attacking him
we'll talk about this because there's
there's now been investigations that
have gone through real-time
investigations people add-ons are
actually going and driving the route wow
right by themselves and then timing it
up with the police scanner video with
the police scanner audio and the videos
that came out from on the scene to
determine the speed of this thing so
we'll get in all this stuff too let's
look i think we know the truth now yeah
we got we got ian what's up everybody
good to see you ian crossland happy to
be here ian crossland.net get some i am
also here in the corner pushing buttons
as i always do i'm delighted to be back
with andrew branca he's very smart guy
and jack of course good pal so we're
gonna have a great talk tonight i'm
stoked before we get started my friends
head over to
strongerbonesandlife.com and you can get
your ageless multi-collagen from
biotrust 51 off this stuff is great
unflavored you mix it in your drinks and
it provides you with collagen you need
it for your skin your nails your joints
all that really important stuff and for
me now truth be told i haven't actually
skated in a little bit because we got
sick and then we had the week in austin
but uh i try to make sure i'm keeping up
with my my protein and my collagen
because i have old man 35 year old knees
and as much as a lot of the older people
are like you're not old i'm like try
jumping down a six foot half pipe with
35 year old knees and you'll know what
i'm talking about so go to
strongerbonesnlife.com
you get a 60-day money-back guarantee
the healthy aging support of collagen
and its ideal forms the five key types
of collagen you need from four different
sources hydrolyzed collagen peptides
meaning better and faster digestibility
to support maximum benefits for every
order today biotrust will donate a
nutritious meal to a hungry child in
your honor through their partnership
with no kid hungry.org to date biotrust
has provided over 5 million meals to
hungry kids please help them hit their
goal of 6 million meals this year the
collagen it's non-gmo it's free of
artificial colors flavors and
preservatives there's nearly no odor or
taste unlike bone broth and other
supplements there's no clumping and you
will get free shipping with every order
free vip live live health and fitness
coaching from biotrust team of expert
nutrition and health coaches for life
with every order and their free e-report
the 14 foods for amazing skin with every
order seriously shout out you guys know
biotrust they sponsor a few shows every
month and i have um just tremendous uh
respect and gratitude to the companies
willing to get behind this show directly
and have us shout them out that means a
lot but don't forget go to timcast.com
become a member we're gonna have a
members only segment coming up around 11
or so p.m but
we are taking the rest of the weekend
off for thanksgiving so that we can have
thanksgiving with friends thanksgiving
with family and you should all do the
same
but at timecast.com you'll get access to
all of our members-only segments as well
as supporting our journalists who are
doing a lot of really great work so
don't forget to like this video
subscribe to this channel share the show
with your friends and over at the tim
cass store tim guys.com click the store
you can get your official step on snack
and find out sure yes i guess youtube
doesn't like it they won't let us put it
up on the channel but it's an amazing
shirt so you guys should get it if you
want it let's jump into this first story
which i imagine youtube will also get
mad at us about check this out from
daily mail waukesha massacre suspect
daryl brooks was convicted for
threatening to bomb nugget casino in
nevada and is still wanted after failing
to appear in court they charged this guy
in 2007 for calling in a bomb threat to
the to the nugget casino he was put on
probation after being convicted of
conspiring to disturb the piece of gross
misdemeanor and was banned from the
casino his rap sheet also includes a
conviction for
let's just say he was trafficking minors
and i believe he had a child with the
minor i mean this guy is is you know
we'll try to keep it family friendly
here not a good not a good guy not good
at all but based on this as well as
other information that's come out what
andy noe reported and i used in my
reporting which really triggered the
media they were so angry oh no don't
tell everybody this guy supports black
lives matter and that he's promoted
black nationalism and that he's
threatened to harm white people because
that's the truth
and so if you look at this and you look
at jack posobik you put out the court
police report
this car was slowly creeping up towards
the parade
it was not a pursuit he was not fleeing
anything and he was going slow enough
that one of the officers was able to
walk up to the car bang on the hood walk
over bang on the door and then the car
speeds through
choosing to go down this path
it was not it was not pursued this was
an intentional act he's been so uh let
me put this away
they've charged to the guy with
intentional homicide
witnesses said he was swerving into
people the police said he was slowly
moving up and they banged the car
telling him to stop he's posted about
how he's wanted to kill white people he
supported black nationalism and black
lives matter
but the media says it was an accident
the media is downplaying this they're
criticizing me and andy no and many
others who are pointing these things out
what do you call it if a guy goes online
threatens harm against white people and
then gets in an suv drives up to a
parade route runs over a bunch of white
people
you just that's just a traffic accident
buddy
you're connecting too many dots over
there what do you even think you're
doing that's not the narrative that's
not what the police officers told us it
was an suv so this is what you get if
you have a guy who goes on social media
and says he wants to harm white people
and then he runs through a parade route
directly through it swerving into people
what you get
is an suv involved in an accident right
well so here's here's what
and you can go see go to waukesha county
dot gov you can see the entire thing
i've got it written up as detective
casey uh officer berlin you know they
come up and they talk about this where
they say it was driving so slow that
they were able to walk up to it knock on
the hood then he brushes them aside but
he's still going slow
then they're able to knock on the window
right and say stop you can't go in there
that's a parade route at that point he
turns and drives so if you go look at
the videos if you freeze it you can
actually see that his um his hood is
already damaged right before he gets
there that's because he had to drive
through barricades to get onto the
parade route so he combined that with
this video
that just uh some add-on went and filmed
himself driving down that road and then
they time it up with the videos and they
realized that you would have to be
driving slow and then speed up but
here's the key here's the key point of
that
and i talked to people locally from the
the myth and form guys you know those
guys yeah they're in milwaukee so
they're telling me they said jack
waukesha it's you know it's not like
some town where you can get stuck
there's a million ways in and out
there's plenty of routes you know it's
ridiculous to even think that you would
somehow be you know accidentally trapped
on a parade route so as the car is
driving you can see this in the dash cam
video
that this guy filmed you have to make a
hard right turn into where the parade
route was so it's that hard right turn
where he would have to smash through the
barricades and then speed up to be able
to go through how that is intent how far
away did uh brooks live
oh
he lived in milwaukee that's like 25
minutes away so did he he came
apparently he came from a domestic
they're saying there or no no they said
there was an altercation nearby i think
it's totally unrelated it's weird so
they're they it was a boat ramp believe
it or not of all things right so there's
a boat ramp that's what you hear on the
police scanner that uh there's this
altercation and there's something about
hey that's actually why the first police
officer went over it see i can pull this
up
that he went over at approximately 4 35
p.m detective casey heard via waukesha
police radio that a reserve officer was
informed by a citizen that two people
were fighting in the area of a of white
rock school squads were sent to that
area to further investigate a few
minutes later detective casey hear into
the horn honking from an area north of
his location and that's where he goes in
and sees him uh
go essentially going into the parade
route i'm just wondering you know this
guy lives so far away why was he out
there right you know i think it's
obvious
i think anybody who looks at the story
says
in the absence of evidence the solution
with the least amount of assumptions
tends to be correct and that looks like
a terror attack again you know a racial
uh racial and political terror attack
based on what this guy had said and
believed and
it's possible it wasn't to be completely
honest but that's the absence of
evidence what we have here is it was an
intentional act it was deliberate and we
can see his motivations uh we can see
some of his uh inclinations on social
media that doesn't mean correct does it
mean motivations but
i think you know when we're dealing with
crimes and stuff it is reasonable for a
person to try and figure out what motive
may have been
at this point it is reasonable to assume
this was a terror attack for racial and
political reasons before real quick we
had
just two days before this the written
house verdict we had an activist
reported on the 20th this was one day an
activist it was reported had said
that this country is a tinderbox and one
more you know one more
match or whatever and it's going to go
up
we had tons of people on the left we had
that democrat in illinois saying it's
karma we had activists on twitter saying
they wanted revenge saying go you know
to to do bad things
and then come sunday
a guy who's made posts about harming
white people goes and does a bad thing
it's absurd to me
do not start with that hypothesis it's
crazy how like if someone
the way the way murder can can happen
and how people will respond differently
like if that guy had been face to face
with each of those individuals looking
in their eyes and using a knife to kill
them each one after the other if this
would be another realm then being behind
the icy cold steel of a car where they
can't see your face it's like a drone
dropping a drone bomb as opposed to
being the one there doing the killing i
mean but he's like i understand that i
understand the drone argument but they'd
be stringing them up if you but actually
like a knife killer and had blood all
over his body and stuff there's there
are two lines here that i was just about
to read and one of them speaks to
exactly what you're talking about
because it says
officer buterin observed the driver
looking straight ahead directly at him
and it appeared he had no emotion on his
face as the vehicle passed his location
he continually yelled for the vehicle to
stop skip ahead a little bit they shot
at him right he they did shoot at him he
hurt the vehicle then appeared so okay
so they knew he was a he was
he was preparing to attack these people
and they tried to use deadly force to
stop it right at that point obviously
they perceived him as an eminent deadly
threat that's why they fired the shots
officer buterin heard tires squeal as
the vehicle appeared to rapidly
accelerate the vehicle took an abrupt
left turn into the crowd of parade
participants at this point it was clear
that this was an intentional act to
strike and hurt as many people as
possible
and so uh i love this if we if we
operate on what the police said they
said they ruled out terror
then i can only say
impulse i mean it's not passion passion
you know
you maybe argue passion what was he mad
about was he like he was driving up and
he saw some karen yelling and he was
like oh now i'm really angry and in this
passionate moment there was no great
passion so it was just likely it would
only matter anyway if the passion was
aroused by the people uses
right so that's clearly not the case so
maybe drugs
i would love to see uh a toxicology
report here oh it would be off the
charts would be my expectation i mean
you ever see that ring video and the mug
shot that's come out i mean this does
not seem like a guy who's operating is
right he'll have everything on that
graph and that may be why the police
said it's not terror because it turns
out the guy's just you know whacked out
of his mind and was just slamming the
gas thinking he was running over gummy
bears or something you know he's just
like trip you know tripping and crazy so
my issue is i would love to believe this
guy was just on drugs i don't want to
live in a world it certainly wouldn't be
the first terrorist attack that was
committed by someone on drugs no for
sure for sure i'm just saying
if someone was on drugs we can then
argue oh okay so so
there's evidence to suggest maybe it
wasn't terror just a drug addict doing
something crazy
there's still i think it's still a fair
assumption that this guy was politically
motivated in what he did i'm just saying
right now there is no evidence of drugs
the only thing we have is this guy's
political statements about wanting to
hurt white people which you know
something about banging heads or
something and then getting a car and
doing this plus the timing plus the
political nature of what's been going on
and so i lean towards not definitively
but i think it's a fair assumption it
was terror if they come out the
toxicology report and say he was on
drugs it would shift more towards the
middle again and i'd say it's still you
know likely it could be terror but it
could also be the guy was whacked out of
his mind so here's my thing too and you
know i had kind of already been thinking
this with um
some of those social media posts that
you and andy were highlighting i went
through a ton of them myself before the
thing got taken down andy andy was
highlighting yeah i was just citing
reporting right right and so and now i
think new york post has put it up daily
mail's put it up
but specifically now of course you know
the anti-white posts the fbi is not
tracking that they're just not but the
anti-police posts that he add up the
post about killing police officers
that's something that definitely would
he had a post about killing cops right
wow talked about you know called them
pigs and this type of thing uh back in
2020 and that's definitely something
that would have put him on the radar so
one of the things that i
was thinking about reading this was and
of course in all of these cases we you
know it seems that we always come up to
an extent where
they were known to the fbi subject was
known to fbi right don't we always do we
always hear about this and so i was
wondering based on those posts i'm like
yeah he's probably in a file somewhere
because that would have pinged the
algorithm
but then we hear this thing
about the casino
and that he threatened to bomb a casino
that's like okay fbi has definitely got
a file on this they know him 100 well in
fairness i'm also known to the fbi i
teach at the academy there
[Laughter]
yeah but i mean i've i've been through
some fbi training myself something i
find interesting about this whole thing
is is we have the story itself right why
did it do this was it intentional were
there drugs kind of the core story but
then there's also the meta-story like
why are all these people instantly
coming to his defense trying to explain
away what happened
or just cover up
he was chased by someone with a knife or
there was a gunfighter there was some
innocent explanation for this it wasn't
actually a an act of malice that that
did this and i think there's a reason
for it i think because this guy is a
real problem for the bail reform
movement
now we've all heard about bail reform
and i believe bail can use reform if
someone's
charged with a non-violent crime and
they're being they can't make 500 bail
and that means they won't be able to
work and pay the rent that's a real
problem that needs to be fixed but
that's not where bail reform in the real
world stops it releases violent people
too and those violent people go back to
their community and create havoc the
same havoc they got arrested for the
first time and you might think well why
would anybody want that why would
anybody want havoc in their neighborhood
but havoc chaos is not bad for business
for everybody it's bad if it's your
neighborhood and you live there
but if you're a benjamin crump for
example you make 10 million dollars
every time there's some kind of
zimmerman case a written house case a
ahmad arbory case these are money making
opportunities in the tens of millions of
dollars for you so chaos is good for so
many ways not just money
hold on so political political yeah
you're saying that
there is a motivation to bring about
bail reform because it results in an
opportunity where a criminal can get
hurt and they can monetize it
chaos is good for some people okay so
i should be clear when i say
people are leveraging bail reform for
political reasons i would say
bail reform overreach not all bail
reform but bail reform that releases
violent charges but you think that many
people are advocating for it i'm not
saying every but some have that in mind
they're like this will create more crime
and more opportunity especially people
with considerable political power like a
benjamin crump i don't mean the
individual social worker who's in favor
right right right right they don't have
any he's a lawyer
monetized right so right the pendulum
has been swinging in favor of loosening
bail requirements more and more and more
until the point they include people
charged with violent crimes and
eventually the pendulum is going to
swing back but when it swings back
that's going to be bad for some people
this case is a perfect example a perfect
warning to the normals in society that
holy cow we all thought that bail reform
was a good thing but it's possible it
goes too far it lets people like this
out on bail well i think bell reform is
a good thing i don't like the bail
system i don't like the idea that we
would say you're presumed innocent but
we're not going to let you out unless
you give us 500 bucks
for violent criminals with a
preponderance of evidence then i'm in
favor of remand as far as i'm concerned
either
it's remand or you're free to go until
you're you're convicted but that means
substantially more people should be
remanded and substantially more people
should be released there's also got to
be some limitations like if someone's a
repeat offender and you've got past
convictions okay well now you're going
to be that's almost everybody well if
that's the case sorry but as a practical
matter
you see very few people go through the
criminal just of the people going
through the criminal justice system on
any given day almost none of them is it
their first time but that
sure but if someone goes in and they've
had a pass conviction
and then
they say okay well it's you know two
thousand dollars if you want to get out
i mean you're going to destroy that
person's life
outright before you've proven them
guilty simply on their past well they
could sit in jail for a long time and
there's and there's more there's there's
too many i mean look at kyle kyle ridden
house when he was like he had to sit
there for 87 days
and he didn't have what he said he had
no running water he was not getting good
food he was losing all this weight and
he was not guilty so and then he two
million dollars to get him out and we
can you know we can talk about the
lawyers and stuff but just on the system
alone one
one aspect that i would so so bail
obviously has been around a long time
this isn't something some new system
that you know just was under like the
trump era or something like that you
know um and trump actually was for uh
you know criminal justice reform
although he was focused more on back end
than than front end and not that i'm a
supporter of the first step movement but
just you know for clarify uh to clarify
that but when it comes to
these types of situations you know
you know you were talking before about
how
the criminal uh citizens arrest law in
the arberry case was something that had
been written during the civil war in
georgia it was still on the books at the
time that has been updated since
well with these cases as well one thing
that i think really ties all of these
together is the is video right we have
video of waukesha we have tons of video
of it we have video of kenosha we had
video of ahmed arberry right and i think
that in those two cases it was the video
that went to the jury and eventually
swung them so you're thinking they
should look at video as part of setting
bail so look at video that would never
happen no look at that never happened
because you have to understand how this
process works in a nutshell
they're trying to make these decisions
in three minutes
right the magistrate is making a bail
decision in three minutes he's got an
algorithm he uses depending on the
degree of the offense
risk of flight there's a set risk of set
criteria that they use and the state and
the defense are going to go down that
checklist of criteria and it's like a
little algorithm it arrives and make it
part of probable cause
well a probable cause would be
determined someplace else it's not going
to be determined right there but a judge
a magistrate's not going to take time to
look through
even five minutes of video to try to
come to self-determination what bail
should be it should be right
but that's what i'm talking about
in the entire system yes the idea we're
talking about redesigning this is the
process is the punishment what they did
to james o'keefe they raid him and his
journals because law enforcement knows
the process is the punishment when it
came to occupy wall street protests
there was a photographer that i was i
was just filming i'm filming and there
was a photographer standing on the
sidewalk minding his own business when
an officer came up and arrested him
they claimed that he was obstructing a
roadway they lied they made it up
they then had a female officer lie under
oath and it wasn't until the national
lawyers guild who i'm not the biggest
fan of used my footage to show that the
police lied he was released did any of
the officers get in trouble they never
do they never they lie all the time on
these criminal complaints they're never
held the issue is if there's someone who
is a regular working class joe and he
gets accused of a somewhat serious
offense but not like not a felony or
anything the judge can be like look i
think we should keep him in jail until
the court and then what 87 days or 80
days you lose your job you lose your
apartment your car gets towed your
people are wondering where you went your
dog is going hungry and then you get out
destitute so so i i i will i will cite
benjamin franklin all day and night it
is better that 100 guilty persons go
free than one innocent person suffer if
the court cannot justify
reasonably an algorithm in three minutes
is not justification for holding someone
against their will when they are
presumed innocent that being said real
quick so this is where i come into the
video that
that being said everybody should keep
and bear arms and a free society means a
society with risks and if we're going to
let out people and i don't think violent
offenders depending on depending on what
they've committed i think that's
reasonable for a judge to be like you're
accused of triple murder or something
okay sorry
right now
well not triple but yeah well yeah
double murder plus you know a bunch of
other charges i can understand why they
would be like
look i'm sorry you're being held because
these are very serious and we're worried
about the safety of others there should
still be some scrutiny there but if
we're gonna let people out on bail then
all we need do is look at the
constitution and say the fifth and sixth
amendment benjamin franklin and and
blackstone and the second amendment
sure so
i don't want to come across as someone
who's defending the way the system is i
think it's broken i mean from my
perspective for example i think probable
cause hearings
are worthless the way they operate today
what's supposed to happen is a probable
cause hearing is supposed to be a filter
to keep people from being dragged into a
full-blown trial
unless there's probable cause to believe
they committed the crime so at trial
they're going to have to prove you
guilty beyond a reasonable doubt if they
can't even show 51 of the evidence going
into that process they shouldn't be able
to drag you into the terribly
destructive dangerous risk of a
full-blown trial but probable cause
doesn't work that way today it doesn't
work like a 51 degree threshold before
you're brought into trial it's
essentially a zero degree threshold the
prosecutor can say whatever he wants he
can get officers to swear whatever they
want nothing's ever checked when things
are later proven to not be true it
doesn't matter they don't say well the
process that got you into trial was
inherently defective so we're going to
let you out well
what we need is a
genuine probable cause hearing the
reason we don't have one i'm not
defending this
this is just the practical way the
system works the reason we don't have
that is because we have so many
criminals going through the system we
could never give everybody a genuine
probable cause hearing the way the
system is designed today and most of the
people going through are criminals so no
one cares that they're not actually
getting a probable cause hearing no one
notices until an innocent person gets
fed into that system and suffers all the
the the
thresher effects of that horribly
destructive system and you see it
affecting an innocent person that way
justice you're just being blind is not
always a good thing here's the example
i'll throw out there and because being
justice isn't blind i don't think but
you've got kyle rittenhouse was charged
what within 24 hours or maybe 36 hours
right if you if you actually go by the
dates right um
alec baldwin it's still under
investigation we're still reviewing the
incident when we when we know that this
took place on a movie set i'm sure every
single minute of that incident is caught
on film there's no relevant facts in
dispute i mean on the criminal charge of
reckless homicide we know all the facts
right not in dispute uh and we know the
law the law's not ambiguous there so the
only reason they haven't charged them is
because they've decided because they
don't want to charge them that's all
right if it was me or you and they
decided they wanted to charge us we
would have been charged that all day
every day and and correct
i'm not a new mexico lawyer i mean i
know you're from out west but crisis
management is there a special is there a
special uh rule for actors there's a
special carve out in the uh
law in my opinion and it wasn't my
opinion it was someone on the show who
mentioned this we saw what gloria allred
said right alec baldwin had a crisis
management firm most likely oh yeah and
he was on the phone immediately i
believe that and they seeded the fake
story about a blank and a misfire and
shrapnel because the real story was that
alec baldwin was handed a gun by someone
who wasn't supposed to give it to him
that neither of them had checked the
weapon that it was loaded live and he
chose to for no reason seemingly no
reason to pull the pull the hammer back
aim it and shoot a woman
the scene did not call for that in any
way and it wouldn't matter if it did and
this is what i was saying um i can't
remember who who was here we were
talking to this i said um if you walk up
to someone aim a gun
[ __ ] the hammer pull the trigger what
are they going to call that intentional
homicide yes alec baldwin however got
got in front of the story so what
happens when at the very least it's a
reckless homicide so the intent element
is different you must have for example
he may not have genuinely not have known
the gun was loaded that would take away
the intent i'm saying but the fact that
he didn't check that's still right alex
baldwin walked in the middle of the
street and there was some woman walking
down the street oh i see sure pulled a
gun and pointed at her and just shot her
intentional you would infer intent from
that conduct right alec baldwin wasn't
supposed to aim [ __ ] and fire a gun in
that scene
so what's the difference i i know you
know
the pattern it's a set so maybe
something's going on but if the script
supervisor the and the electrician and
other witnesses there said he wasn't
supposed to be given the gun by that
person and then he chose to point it
pulled you know with live rounds like
what's the difference the difference is
if you're just in the middle of the
street you're not involved in a movie
set and you walk up to a woman point the
gun pull the trigger blow her brains out
that conduct is conduct because we never
know intent right we can't read inside a
person's mind we're inferring their
intent from their conduct and you can
infer from that conduct they intended to
shoot that woman because there's no
alternative hypothesis consistent with
the conduct there is in the in the
baldwin case because he was on a movie
set so there may be some other reason
why he did this without intending to
kill her but he did kill her there's no
justified reason for her killing her he
could have avoided killing her by taking
the simple step of confirming himself
that the gun did not have around it is a
violation of standard protocols to aim a
weapon guns are inherently dangerous
instruments the standard of care is
strict liability if it goes off when you
pull the trigger and a bullet goes
through somebody that's on you i think
it's murder you don't get to say oops i
think gloria allred had the the great
line of it she said you handed alec
baldwin that gun and he decided to play
russian roulette with it i i i think
people keep giving him the benefit of
the doubt every
turn it's insane to me he we we we now
know the stories were all lies we know
that he had no reason to aim that gun at
a person because it's a violation of his
decades of security training of firearms
training on movie sets he's been in
movies action movies witnesses have
testified he's got multiple training
that a.d wasn't supposed to give him the
gun he had literally no reason and it
was a violation of safety protocol to
aim it at a person it wasn't part of the
scene and there was a dispute with the
crew over what was going on i mean look
you look at all the stories that all the
news that has come out and it sounds
much more like alec baldwin has an anger
management problem so he took a gun
angrily pointed at the camera person and
shot and killed her and then freaked out
that makes substantially more sense than
the armorer made a mistake who
accidentally handed it to the a.d who
made a mistake who gave it to baldwin
who made a mistake who accidentally
aimed it at her pulled the hammer back
it's a single action revolver and then
shot her with it and then a fake story
gets seated i'm not playing so you're
saying he could have been could have
been frustrated about something's going
wrong on the side
moment right so he's yelling at her
saying something and notice we still to
this day have not seen any video of this
we haven't even seen a sanitized video
we haven't seen anything and there are
multiple cameras filming this obviously
so my gut would say that's an overreach
i don't know for sure but i will say
this it's no crazier than what the
written house prosecutor argued
i think i'd say it's much more
reasonable
let's talk about let's go back to
reasonable let's talk about what's going
on with the with the press and waukesha
we have the story from the examiner
nbc labels waukesha attack an accident
oh it's better it's better we got it's
not just an accident it wasn't just a
guy on tv saying well you know the
accident here we've got cnn waukesha
parade crash suspect crash
is is is crash an intentional homicide
act okay i'll just jump over to google
vehicle plows through parade there's
times of india good on them cnn crash
fox has media blasted for calling it a
crash cnn waukesha crash eight-year-old
victim of the crash parade incident
parade incident bbc says they are all
terrified to say it was intact even
though the dude's been charged with
intentional homicide i was intentional
homicide i believe right it was
charged with which i did i read just
read the criminal complaint that's
it's amazing to me because
you could have you have all of the
evidence and all of the elements in that
criminal committee that is a terroristic
criminal complaint the only difference
is that the charge isn't there and what
the police i guess is the chief of
police says at the press conference if
you had added up all of those facts and
you add in then one more paragraph of
the statements that he had made online
the years and years worth of statements
you know what you have
you have charlottesville yep you have
the charlottesville 2017 james fields
attack and they're all the same facts
imagine if they found found similar
statements except
that that wasn't a christmas parade they
were there i mean so this is worse i
mean so exactly so the thing about
charlottesville is that you have two
angry faces i'm talking about from the
complaint side not the situation right
right right uh you have two fighting
sides all day it's nuts the cops aren't
stopping and people are
did you cover that i was not injured
but a guy you know fired a gun at one
dude berkeley that was it yeah yeah
and then one guy's flame throwing
another guy and then a dude gets in his
car you had mutual combat
you're a lot of music oh definitely and
then uh i i can't speak to you know
what's going through people's minds but
i can tell you what the video shows
fields then starts driving down a road
towards a large group they run up and
start bashing his car and he just slams
the gas and rams into people
so there's a lot of heat of the moment
elements in that combat all day driving
down the road the dude slams the gas he
claimed i believe he was trying to
escape i don't think i believe him when
you have mutual combat and then a guy
engages in very serious attacks on
another group sorry you don't get that
benefit of the doubt but in in in
waukesha
he like see he drove to a parade he
sought this out there was no combat here
it was little kids marching down the
street twirling batons and he plows
through
this is
worse well so let me let me go read and
this is what i was getting at i have
the wikipedia articles and i
screenshotted these earlier today
here is the one for waukesha
2021 waukesha christmas parade car crash
on november 21 2021 an suv was driven
through suv was driven through no name
of the driver the driven through the
annual christmas parade in waukesha
wisconsin almost makes it sound like
it's part of the parade it's so passive
right driven through the parade killing
six people and injuring 62 others then
we get the alleged driver of the vehicle
39 year old daryl lee brooks is in
custody brooks has been charged with
five degrees of first degree intentional
homicides actually hasn't been updated
because he's been charged with six now
yeah
once again wikipedia's fake news going
now i have i'll read this one there we
go
and this one and then the next one is
charlottesville
and of course i can't find it right now
so on in charlottesville though you get
the driver you get the fact that he had
made a series it starts by saying a
white supremacist yeah
oh here it is the charlottesville car
attack the charlottesville car attack
was a white supremacist terrorist attack
terrorist attack terrorist attack right
there perpetuated on august 12 2017 when
james alex fields jr deliberately drove
his car into a crowd of people
peacefully protesting the unite the
right rally in charlottesville virginia
killing one person and injuring 35.
20-year-old fields had previously
espoused neo-nazi and white supremacist
beliefs and drove from ohio to attend
the rally so i think it's very important
to point out that this comparison
intends uh the intention is to show the
waukesha attacker
is comparable to what happened in
charlottesville a a someone who
committed a violent act against a group
of people
and their horrifying attacks but the
media
over or like just just absolutely slams
charlottesville every moment they get
and waukesha i think yesterday cnn you
had a candidate in virginia that just
last what a week ago a month ago ran his
entire campaign was based around
charlottesville joe biden launched the
current president of the united states
launched his campaign based on
charlottesville this has been a seminal
moment in american politics well i think
it's fairly obvious
there are a bunch of people posting
about how they they they can assume
the race of the individual based on the
fact that the media won't report it and
it's actually uh not fair it's actually
it could be it's the coulter rule is
that what it is
or coulter's law but but i think it's
fair to say if they don't report the
race you could just assume the person is
not white yes because it's not about any
one particular minority group it's just
about the the media has no problem you
know actually they enjoy saying like a
white person did this so you know there
a lot of people were pointing out
what do you think would happen in our
berry every every moment of it what do
you think would happen if in the press
uh we had a story about a white man with
years of posts about how he doesn't like
black people gets in a car drives to a
black suburb and then rams a black
christmas parade what would the media
imagine if kyle rittenhouse had had
messages like that
house
right now right now didn't have
anti-black anything no no no no but i'm
saying what are you saying if you did we
would never have heard anything but that
for the entire trial that's it right i
mean the the proud boys photo you get
the one hand gesture which you know
he even claims now was something that
was a setup he actually did claim that
in his last interview with um
with ashley banfield on on news nation
and i really like news nation by the way
a lot of stuff a lot of the work they're
doing i think they're trying to kind of
be what cnn was at one point you know
just kind of show both sides and not
really try to take a side in 1991 yes
[Laughter]
um i mean like the original original
iteration watching those old keith
olbermann videos kind of sad to see how
psychotic i know right and then
you also of course had bingo trying to
make use of kyle rittenhouse's social
media in the trial he bought he fought
for that uh that supposed proud boys
meeting photos he fought desperately to
get that into evidence no but he did use
his tick tock remember that oh yeah
that's the the vo was your
tick tock account four doors you know
right yes
the only reason he was able to use that
was because kyle's
profile picture in there had him holding
right the rifle wow that's what made it
admissible i got to give a shout out to
deborah messing
deborah messing yeah the wrong side of a
lot of things we're usually criticizing
her for but today she tweeted
dear mainstream media a man
intentionally drove a car through a
parade killing six and injuring 50 plus
it was not an accident fire emoji call
it by its name waukesha massacre and it
was a domestic terror attack don't
minimize police bravo
okay yeah
when the when celebrities and media are
lying and omitting and covering up and
then deborah messing i mean look she's
had a lot of tweets i've been like oh
geez you know what what a crazy i'm
pretty sure she's about she's been on
suraj's list a couple times i'm sure she
has probably maybe not i don't know but
she came out she got it right and i i
completely agree she's right and then it
trended after that as well waukesha
massacre she started that she's i
believe she was the one who started that
trend and i think everybody was just
shocked that here's somebody who's you
know not not just known as you know your
typical prototypical hollywood you know
kind of lefty i mean she's like
like
blue and on like george takei
level kind of just
occupied democrats i'm pretty sure
george doesn't actually run his own
twitter account i'm sure he doesn't i'm
sure he has a company do it and that's
why he sounds insane all the time yeah
and you're like
he's probably just sitting in a room
with like a warm blanket on his lap like
in the sun
half asleep being old and someone's
tweeting away on his thing you know like
gravel institute you know mike gravel
you know right now
he's not even live anymore yeah yeah
right right right
so much for red flag laws then right
someone complains about you your
ex-girlfriend complains about you the
police come and take all your guns away
because you could be dangerous turns out
you don't need a gun to kill a bunch of
people you just you can just get a ford
escape and run it through a parade there
was someone who actually suffered
i mean this has been a talking point for
some time but the point i i bring up is
that every day you live in a city you
cross a street with these gigantic
multi-ton vehicles flying at you and
you're not scared of getting hit why
any one of those people could decide to
just hurt and kill dozens so new york
city of all places and they don't do it
it did happen a couple of years ago it
does happen it did it it was like it
happened a lot in the summer of 2015 or
16 in europe and this is interesting to
me because i remember how the bbc and
some of these overseas organizations
characterized these
mysterious car attacks exactly like the
u.s media is characterizing this they
were literally terror attacks
perpetrated by foreigners who'd come
into like for example the uk and france
and they would not cover
where these people are coming from what
their ideologies might have been they
only covered that it was a car attack
the motive may never be known this is
why when you go to a christmas market
and tanya and i um a couple years ago we
were going through and visiting
christmas markets in europe that before
we had kids obviously and
[Music]
there are barricades up before you can
go into in every country in europe with
the exception of poland not estonia well
in in europe right now i don't even know
who'd want to be there considering the
extremity uh
the lockdowns that's been happening not
poland and and not in poland and
australia
australia is getting real dark but we we
can talk about that a little bit let's
uh we'll keep it in line with this
because we have more news this is
actually fairly big we got the story
from timcast.com all three men found
guilty of murder in ahmed arbury case
this is the story about
the a man who had gone to this
neighborhood several times he had
entered a building on on multiple
occasions uh i believe he was actually a
felony suspect is that was it those that
was in the in the trial i think that
even the prosecution said yes oh yeah a
felony suspect burglary suspect
in this instance yeah yeah well so what
so this is from actual justice warrior
he had tweeted that in the case
the issue was
they all agreed that he was actually
suspected of committing burglaries oh
the police were going door-to-door but
not that
of the guy right yeah but not that day
and so the issue was they did not have
actual knowledge of anything he had he
had done it that day but i don't i'll
give you the context real quick all
three men were found guilty and the
craziest thing about it is
the third guy
he was just following in his car and
filming what was happening and then he
public he gave the footage like hey look
and they prosecuted this guy's going to
prison for the rest of his life for
filming this so you're we're getting a
lot of conservatives first of all the
entire entirety of the left is cheering
when they announced the verdict a guy in
the courtroom was like woo and then the
judge was like get him out of my
courtroom no outbursts and all who
outside are cheering and celebrating
which is funny considering they just
said the justice system was broken
because of written house but they're
cheering for it and then i see a bunch
of conservatives cheering for it and i'm
like
i think y'all are wrong on this one in
in a certain sense
legally speaking on the law yep that
jerry got it right the judge gave him
instructions these guys did not have a
right to get in their trucks grab a
shotgun and go chase down some dudes
surround him but there's a lot of of
context here that says to me i think
these these i think the two guys the
mcmichaels these are the two guys who
are directly involved with getting their
vehicle in the gun and then confronting
the father and the son father and the
son i believe they deserve charges i
don't know if you know sending them for
decades in prison makes sense but they
should have been charged for a lot of
for you know on something the third guy
who was just filming i mean this is i
just so was the ruling then that he was
part of the pursuit is that the
surrounding part of that but it was they
had also charged him with aggravated
assault yeah uh using his pickup truck
which doesn't mean you have to cause
injury it means you put someone else in
fear of injury right uh so
it wasn't just that he was filming it's
it's right it was the aggravated assault
which is a felony and that's then he
died so it's felony murder which only
emerges
i think on the law this is the right
ruling and i think that's what most
people are saying so i'll just put it
this way the the dude was a burglary
suspect that was with not uh up for can
he was not uh contested
but you have in the video that came out
two via i think it's two vehicles or
maybe just a truck and aubry is seen
running towards that truck but you got a
guy following behind him so he's not
going to turn around he's got to run
towards the guy with the shotgun and
i'll tell you this
between two trucks in fairness he's not
limited to the street you could run to
the right
350 degrees of other directions right he
could run in and it's not like the
trucks went up on the lawns of
properties chasing but if they had been
following him for for several minutes he
knew they were following him in his mind
he may have been like i can't get away
from these guys this guy's holding a
shotgun
my only way out of this is to fight back
well maybe but that's not an element of
the crimes against them right if he had
gotten the gun and shot them and been
charged with shooting them and he raised
the legal defense of self-defense then
the reasonableness of his perception
would be relevant but it's it's not
relevant with respect to these criminal
charges what would your analysis be
given given that were the case well it's
it's
hypothetically yeah no
what complicates it is he wasn't just
someone recreationally jogging i mean we
know this right you'd have to erase your
mind of everything else around him that
but they're still in the home i know
they are and that's
you know that just makes proper legal
analysis more complicated because
there's a lot of misinformation
disinformation and if you believe that
stuff you come to a different outcome
but this guy was in that home repeatedly
in the middle of the night this is not
somebody recreationally visiting a
construction site
and and there had been burglaries there
had been robberies a gun had been stolen
yeah not even a month prior and when
when when we say that the mcmichaels uh
didn't know exactly what he was doing
that day they knew the other stuff and
the other stuff can play a role in your
assessment of probable cause
if a police officer had seen those
videos of him there those other times
and then saw him apparently leaving the
building again that day the police
officer is not required to pretend he
doesn't know that past experience those
past events he's allowed to consider
that in coming to a determination of
probable cause on that day even if he
didn't see explicitly burglar-like
activity that they he's seen
burglar-like activity from this guy on
this property on previous experience so
let me ask you and i think the answer is
obvious but you being the attorney on
self-defense if travis mcmichael
who has not been convicted on all counts
if he actually was a police officer who
did the exact same thing
what would have happened uh he would
never have been charged never never they
wouldn't even bring charges no and so so
here's here's the crazy thing
there's a there's a vehicle behind ahmed
arbury so i can certainly understand why
he's like you know these guys are after
me i don't think he was a good dude i
think he had you know mal intent but
you know don't surround people like if
you're you're i i can certainly
understand why but of course the defense
was that they weren't the defense was
there was no coordination between those
two vehicles right so they weren't like
a pack of walls surrounding somebody um
look i i i get it but i also feel like
you know just i think about what i would
be doing if i was running down the
street and then a car comes up behind me
in cars in front of me so we can we can
listen right but again we're confusing
it because you have to think what would
i be doing if that happened to me and i
was engaged in felony burglary behavior
right you know why they're following you
you're not a recreational jogger who's
suddenly being approached by men with
shotguns that's not what's happening no
no no
you're saying there's a reason the hands
don't go up and it's hey guys
in the context of these guys not being
law enforcement
like this guy's gonna fight but here's
what i'm getting to ahmed arbury runs i
think he would have fought if they were
law enforcement oh i agree i agree so i
think what he's getting at is that this
guy
didn't want to be stopped right for
night for anything
because ran to the right from the
around the right side of the truck got
around it and then flanked left
grabbed the shotgun from travis
mcmichael they fought over it
a shot was fired hitting ahmet arbory
and he died now i want to stop and i
want to give you the real context in a
more
in the spirit of what i think is a fair
assessment
the the media the left will tell you and
that's what they did say that a bunch of
racists got in a pickup truck and chased
down a jogger and lynched him which is a
psychotic
lie what actually happened a couple
local guys who had been hearing reports
about burglaries from the police
heard this guy was spotted in their
neighborhood again again again a gun had
been stolen about a month earlier
they say hey we got to figure out who
this guy is we got to check him out
we're gonna we're they they probably
didn't think anything other than we got
to stop this guy what does that mean it
could mean nothing it could be like
let's just get in our car and go after
them actually hold on hold on
so so
they they they they knew a gun was
stolen
that's why travis mcmichael had a
shotgun
hey someone stole a gun if he's got a
gun we could be in trouble and if we try
and say hey what are you doing here and
even try and talk to him he could have a
gun
when they stop their truck and as you
argue the defense argue there's no
coordination he gets out with a shotgun
he is legally allowed to keep and bear
arms
when ahmed arboury ran around the truck
and then grabbed the gun and fought with
them there was now dual possession of
that weapon
in the fight a shotgun blast killed
ahmed arboree so i look at that nominee
man i understand the letter of the law
they got the conviction but doesn't it
feel like something doesn't make sense
or doesn't add up properly the narrative
for the mainstream media is a lie of
course does this mean the provocation
argument kind of that we were talking
about in kyle rittenhouse
uh well the prosecution did raise the
issue of provocation in her closing
statement and wasn't a major part of the
trial no i see um
i think
and suddenly i lost my train of thought
um
go ahead eminem did the guy watch the
shot i was throwing it back to you
the guy with the shotgun brandished the
shotgun he was holding it uh i think he
was just holding it and then ahmed aubry
look oh i remember what i was going to
say so he's in front of the truck to the
left sorry and then ahmed army goes
around it and can't actually see travis
mcmichael and then comes around the
front and attacks him and
charges him it's unknown whether
mcmichael ever brandished
well it's disputed the video is very
fuzzy at that point and there's parts
where they're obscured by the truck in
front so you can't really see what's
happening
but of course either way it has to prove
guilt beyond a reasonable doubt but i
don't think it matters because if he's
pointing at that point he's being
charged by someone yeah
is on camera
going around the car and at this point
there is no gun pointed at him and he
chooses then to turn left and engage
travis mcmichael
so it's it's much more complicated than
malice murder and felony murder but they
just said you know across the board so
here's here's the thing i want to make
clear because there's obviously a lot of
emotions around this it's a racially
energized case i don't care about these
guys getting convicted and going to
prison on any kind of personal level i
don't know these people they're not
friends of mine they weren't my client
what happens to them is a very little
consequence to me on any kind of
personal level but professionally i care
a lot about the legal process and i care
a lot about due process and if they're
going to get convicted it ought to be
done the right way and that didn't
happen here
because the whole case rested on this
citizen's arrest statute and your
interpretation of it there were two
possible interpretations lawyers in that
courtroom and me myself outside the
courtroom with lots of other lawyers we
in good faith argued different different
positions on that citizens arrest law
the judge wasn't sure exactly what it
meant when all the legal experts can't
decide on what it means
someone has to make the call you can't
have an a version and a b version one of
which favors the prosecution one of
which favors the defense and whichever
one is chosen decides the whole case and
both parties know that the prosecution
knows oh my gosh if i don't get my
version i lose this trial these guys
walk well and the defense knows if we
don't get our version our clients are
going to get convicted there's no other
possible outcome so somebody has to
decide which version is the jury going
to get and that's the responsibility of
the judge in this case
real quick what are these rights
same thing yeah
one of the virgins one of the virgins
ah
i guess there should be 72 of those
right
essentially one of the versions is that
the citizens arrest could only be lawful
if everything was contemporaneous and
they had essentially perfect knowledge
that a felony burglary had occurred and
of course the defense never claimed
either of those things because
th that didn't exist right they didn't
know for a fact that he'd committed
felony burglary and the the felony
felony burglary like conduct they were
aware of was not contemporaneous with
their efforts to arrest them what does
that mean contemporaneous happening at
the same time right so they had they had
evidence of felony-like behavior but it
was from a week earlier two weeks ago so
it's like it's like they didn't see him
walk up smash the window go in and grab
a bunch of stuff that is the state
position that's what they would have had
to see in that moment to make the
citizens uh arrest lawful that's the
state position and if that position is
accepted well then they're convicted
because they don't have any of that yeah
the defense position is well no it's the
knowledge is first of all doesn't have
to be absolute doesn't have to be in his
presence because he was an apparent
felon in flight the standard should be
probable cause that's what the statute
says probable cause not certainty and
probable cause can be based on knowledge
not gained only in that moment but prior
knowledge that you're aware of
surveillance video of the guy in the
house that you've seen that's part of
your knowledge base it's part of why you
believe it's probable
that he's now also committing a felony
burglary if you have that definition
that favors the defense it's probably an
acquittal so these two competing
versions one wins for the state one wins
for the defense the judge had his duty
was to make a call look
we don't know which one of these really
should apply but on the judge i decide
what the law is going to be as presented
to the jury now when he makes a decision
later on he might be reversed appellate
court might say no you chose a it should
have been b or the reverse
but it's also true
that
there's only one way to actually make
that decision because there's a legal
doctrine called the doctrine of lenity
and it says if a statute is ambiguous in
criminal law
the benefit of the doubt is always given
to the defense
not to the state so because the state
drafted the law the state passed the law
the state was in control of how
unambiguously that statute was written
you can't hold that against the
defendant so if the judge was going to
pick one of those versions under the
doctrine of leninity he would be obliged
to pick the version that favored the
defense and then we're looking at
acquittals for these guys and the city
would have burned to the ground right
maybe many cities so he decided well i'm
not going to make that decision so he
punches i'm not going to do my job i'm
going to take the ambiguous version both
options give them to the jury and let
them decide
and that's not the job of the jury the
crazy thing to me is um you know like i
i tweeted basically about i mean i read
your article i did a video on it and i
tweeted like this could result in an
appeal is that fair to say they'll oh
yeah there's fertile ground for appeal
here but right people need to keep in
mind appeals i like to say appeals are
for losers
and that's technically true right you're
only appealing literally
that's right obviously here's
the interesting thing here for one i
mean there could be but things do get
overturned
look looking at this
you have kyle rittenhouse who was
fleeing
and you have ahmed arbury who is
engaging
you can argue that by putting the pickup
truck there and then having behind him
that you know it was a fight-or-flight
reflex but he didn't have to attack them
and go for the gun
so i i was thinking about that in
regards to your previous statements on
cal rittenhouse about how the mentality
of anthony huber for instance has no
bearing on the self-defense right of
kyle rittenhouse anthony huber could
believe he stopped being a mass shooter
but he's still threatening kyle who has
a right to self-defense right in this
instance i'm curious about
the different potentialities here
i mean just what's your assessment on
what is transmitting michael defending
it all comes back to that citizen's
arrest law if you believe the citizens
arrest was unlawful
well then it makes sense that arbory
would defend himself and he would have a
right to defend himself against an
unlawful arrest but let me ask you
something i mean is this whole case
seems to be an issue of the context
provided by the mcmichaels what if they
just said we just happened to be
standing there legally bearing arms and
you attacked me
well we of course we know that's not
true because they gave statements to the
police at the scene that's why they were
it's the con so so these guys oh these
guys had just kept their mouth shut that
wouldn't you couldn't have had a process
and then a video
that guy released the video thinking it
would examine that
they gave the statements and months went
by i mean the the prosecutors remember
the original prosecutor passed on
charges yeah i mean he actually wrote a
memo saying no this was lawful citizen's
arrest and therefore everything is you
know was within the boundaries of the
law it was political
the charges came back because there was
political outrage
well again after the video came out this
is a money making opportunity for some
people that's right this is the point
that i keep bringing it back to
and
we now live in a society that is
governed by viral videos whatever the
last viral video that came out is now
the new discussion and if it comes out
remember george floyd started with a
viral video um the
the central park karen which actually
turned out to be false that started with
a video a very selectively edited video
which the guy who posted it actually
later debunked on his own facebook
because he said he did provoke her i
said he said he was going to take it he
said he was going to take her dog and
then she freaks out thinking that the
stranger's about to take my dog so the
problem though that we have in society
is that we now live in a mass
surveillance society
but george orwell who got a lot right
got this wrong it's not big brother
that's the only one that's in on the
game of mass surveillance it's everyone
little brother all severely each other
right lots of little brothers lots of
little sisters my and so the question
then becomes what do we do with all this
kyle rittenhouse if
there were no video he would be in jail
for the rest of his life yep
because it would be his word against the
word of the other people in that mob and
it would be very very hard for him to
get off without that video but
with these guys the mcmichaels they're
going to jail because of video my
understanding is that um i could be
wrong it's been a while it's been almost
two years now but the uh the guy was
named brady or something um brian or
something the third guy yeah the third
guy he released the video because i
think people in the community were
calling him murderers and he was like no
like look it was it was self-defense
i'll show you the video and then
everyone was like whoa
hey and that's one of those videos where
people will see what they want to see in
that video and you will never change
anybody's mind some people see that
video and they see
a felony suspect charging a man who has
a shotgun in his hands fighting that man
for a shotgun and dying in the effort
and by the way when they show those
gruesome wound scenes of on arbory those
are the same wounds that the mcmichaels
would have feared they would have
suffered if he had gotten control of
that shotgun right it's exactly the same
thing but other people look at that
video and what they see is they see a
rosenbaum they see a black man who was
chased by a bunch of rednecks and is
desperately fighting for his life
because it fits a narrative right and
what if uh do you uh i think there's no
point asking if we you know what aubry
would have done with the gun but
considering he went for the shotgun and
is visibly fighting for it
what would have happened if aubrey got
the gun and shot them
he would be charged and it would
wouldn't be president if i was his
attorney i'd be arguing self-defense
yeah yeah but i don't think it would be
in the press nobody would know about it
it would not be new well no small
georgian community you don't know i mean
if george zimmerman had been killed by
trayvon martin we never would have heard
about the case right right that's what
i'm saying
it would just be another but i also i
also think it's fair to say that if they
didn't go out there with the shotgun we
also wouldn't be hearing about this case
because a fight would have broken out
that would have been the end of it but
you could say that for any case well
it's it's it's true and i want to stress
people have a right to keep and bear
arms it's it's not every case i disagree
with that so i i think there's a lot of
debate to be had around the nature of
the citizen's law statute whether this
judge did his job and i believe he did
not i
that doesn't mean these guys didn't
exercise poor judgment that was poor
judgment by the way written house also
exercised poor judgment if i had a 17
year old son i would not say hey a good
idea let's uh you know take the ar go
down to the right
but poor judgment's not a crime i mean
as a guy who's got an ex-wife thank god
poor judgment is not a crime so they're
not charged with that they're charged
with specific offenses with specific
elements and specific
defenses with specific elements and one
of those is citizen's arrest and how
that law is supposed to be applied
and when you just give the jury the job
of deciding how the law works the only
non-experts in the courtroom by the way
the courtroom is full of lawyers there's
three prosecutors there's
six defense attorneys and a judge and
none of them can figure out what the
statute's actually supposed to mean but
we're going to let 12 jurors untrained
in the law right do that job let me ask
you uh in your opinion based on the
facts of the case do you think
these men should have been convicted
you know i
my view of justice is different i don't
think about the outcomes per se i don't
really care about the outcomes per se in
my view justice is about the process
not about the outcome well
i'm asking because i'm i was going to
ask you then on the judge's ruling so
the first thing i want to understand is
you know based on your understanding of
the case and the law as you've read it
do you think it should have been an
acquittal or
i think there was reasonable doubt that
they had probable cause
to try to make a citizens right and by
the way just
you lean towards an acquittal is what
you're saying
yes but i don't want people to
misunderstand i don't by that i i don't
mean like i think it's more likely than
not that they had probable cause but
that's not the legal standard the
standard isn't whether they were
probably right the standard is
is there a reasonable doubt that they
could have been right do they you know
could they
the math gets complicated but could they
have had a 51 percent belief that he was
a felony burglary suspect
is that enough by a reasonable doubt so
a very tiny belief that they might have
had probable cause should be sufficient
for an acquittal the reason i ask is
do you have like so you've mentioned the
judge didn't do his job in defining and
instructing properly do you have a view
of how it should have been instructed
yes so my reading of the statute favors
the defense
because there's there's basically
it's amazing how ambiguous it is because
it's only two sentences so it's not like
in the in the kyle rittenhouse case they
had that gun statute where you had to
refer to this other statute and then you
had to refer to two other statutes
beyond that and it got very kind of well
in some sense it's complicated
this is only a two sentence statute but
the first sentence talks about kind of
citizen's arrest generally and it says
you have to have immediate knowledge or
presence and the second sentence speaks
specifically to a felon in flight and
there it says probable cause and some
people believe you got to read those two
together
and others my position is you have to
read them separately because it doesn't
make any sense to read them together so
the way i read it it says look for
citizens arrest generally and that means
for like misdemeanors like shoplifting
for you know the the smallest arrestable
offense you have to have
presence or immediate knowledge
that's 100 certainty you saw it happen
right that's not probable cause that's
not you think it's likely it happened
you saw it happen it happened in your
presence you have immediate knowledge
to believe that that's
you ha you start with a hundred percent
that's the requirement but then if it's
a felony in pursuit you also have to
have 51 percent i mean you're already at
100. can i i want to read it for this is
from your article from legal
insurrection it says
that the two sentences are a private
person may arrest an offender if the
offense is committed in his presence or
within his immediate knowledge if the
offense is a felony and the offender is
escaping or attempting to escape a
private person may arrest him upon
reasonable and probable grounds of
suspicion so how i read that is
generally like even for a misdemeanor if
you want to arrest somebody for a
misdemeanor you have to have absolute
knowledge presence or immediate
knowledge you saw them shoplift that
item
but for the special circumstance of a
felon in flight
in that case it's then probable cause 51
is certain because and that makes sense
to me because we're treating them
differently look an arrest is a profound
constraint of your liberty right this
makes your assessment makes total sense
yeah but before we let you and by the
way that applies to cops the standard
for cops is that they want to arrest
somebody for a misdemeanor they have to
have seen it they don't have to have
seen it for a felony right so this
actually if if we put these two
requirements together what we're
actually saying is it's it's
it's harder to arrest somebody who's a
felon in pursuit than it is to a
wrestler isn't this kind of like wait
wait wait just put it back in in a
common sense right couldn't this isn't
this also just the situation of hey stop
that guy
yeah right hey stop that guy he stole a
purse hey stopped that guy he stole my
phone
that's right that's what i was saying
that's 50. so right so i didn't see him
steal the phone but i'm hearing someone
say hey this guy stole my phone stop
that guy you you mean if you want to
make that legal you made a good point
about you know this guy who is a
burglary suspect who was entering his
home repeatedly when you operate from
the leftists false narrative that this
guy was just jogging the story is very
different a couple rednecks accused a
jogger of a crime he didn't commit and
then confronted him with a shotgun he
defended himself when you know all the
facts you know that these guys were
scared because you know as i mentioned a
gun had been stolen there had been
burglaries you guys mentioned that the
police had actually handed out his photo
is that what they did
i forget if they were showing i think
they were showing photos around from the
video they were showing the capture the
video from uh when he was inside the
home in the middle of the night right so
maybe not like a mug shot right if you
see this guy in the neighborhood call us
because we have a video there was
reporting though that one of the i
believe was the older mcmichael had
known of arberry from a previous
investigation but he didn't connect the
dots uh yeah so
so arbory had been um he had brought a
gun to school i believe it was a felony
conviction oh wow uh so he he was an
adult who went to some school event so
he was volunteering it was like a
football game yeah yeah yeah i remember
this i i i forget the status of it was
convicted of the felony or if it was
expunged or i don't remember the details
so i don't want to overstate it but it
was a felony charge for sure because he
brought the gun and then he fought the
cops when they tried to arrest him for
having the gun to school it was a big
mess and the prosecutor's office
investigated that event and the
investigator was greg mcmichaels so he
they'd had some exposure to each other
right right but there's no evidence that
at the time of this day when arbor was
shot that greg mcmichael recognized him
this this uh which would have made a
huge difference by the way because that
would have been a huge contributor to
cause and reason to fear i i always
respect that because that's getting
these two sentences real quick just very
simply a private person may arrest an
offender if the offense is committed in
his presence or within his immediate
knowledge if the offense is a felony and
the offender is escaping or attempting
to escape a private person may arrest
him upon reasonable and probable grounds
of suspicion i think your assessment is
very reasonable to put it simply if
someone commits a misdemeanor you have
to know they did it if someone you
believe your probable cause to come has
committed a felony you would probably
believe they just killed somebody they
just murdered someone that person and
they're in flight right so they're not
waiting for the cops to show up right
they're in flight they're a a reasonably
perceived felon you only probably which
seems to be a situation where you want
to empower the citizenry for the more
serious
right for the more serious so burglary
is a felony yes so they believed that at
some point this was a person who
committed a burglary under the statute
he was trying to escape they had grounds
to stop him that's the defense right but
the prosecution said all of these things
have to be true right which makes no
sense which makes no sense no to apply
both standards to apply say all right
every every citizen's arrest no matter
what has to have a hundred percent
certainty
but a felony a felon in flight well that
also requires fifty one percent
once you have 100 to make them decide
who isn't going through to the level we
are here and they don't have you or to
put it another way if the first sentence
applies to everything including felons
in pursuit why do you need the second
sentence right exactly and a normal
statutory interpretation does not allow
you to presume that a substantive part
of a statute is there for no purpose but
i think one of the big questions was
whether or not
probable cause applies to uh
it's it's probably what you're saying i
think what the prosecution argued was
their knowledge from previous incidents
has no bearing on their right to commit
a citizen's arrest today right well she
didn't say it that explicitly but she
would only say what they knew that day
they didn't see anything that looked
like felony burglary that day yep right
because remember she couldn't they
couldn't they the judge prevented her
from using the prosecutor from using the
jogger narrative and yet for what a year
that had already been seated throughout
the community jogger jogger jogger
jogger jogger i mean this notion that he
was just a recreational jogger going
through the neighborhood is ridiculous i
mean because a recreational jogger going
through a neighborhood is not in
someone's home at night repeatedly even
if he was just loitering there was no
evidence of burglary that day if you're
in someone's home in the middle of the
night without any explanation it's
reasonable to infer it's a burglar was
he in a house that night or it's a house
it's it's a house under construction but
it's a house they saw him exit the house
under construction he's on camera well
he's in that night i thought this was
from an earlier no earlier earlier
nights the cameras from earlier nights
yeah okay so
because this event took this event took
place during the day yeah yeah they just
saw he was right he was he was right by
the house i guess it sounds like it was
ruled properly
in this instance i mean i don't have all
the data well it's like cole bear saw
him and chased him it sounds sounds like
first of all this definitely should have
shouldn't have happened take pictures
call the police and say
you know we hey we just saw the guy we
just saw the guy he's here i mean that's
what i think most reasonable people
would do
but there's a there's a question here
about
man it just something doesn't sit right
with the idea that someone can come into
your community be a burglary suspect
keep going into these homes people are
worried guns go missing and then you
just sit back and say that's that's the
current state of our our country we just
sit back and let this guy do it because
the cops can't stop him and by the way
this happens repeatedly right this is a
common theme in these events so in the
george zimmerman event
uh he was living in an apartment complex
that was being ravaged by burglaries and
home invasions they would call the
police the police would show up the bad
guy was already gone the neighborhood
couldn't take it anymore they said we
have to do something ourselves they
started a neighborhood watch group
zimmerman joins the neighborhood watch
group sees trayvon martin that night and
we have everything that happens he was
trying to do a good thing for his
community to fight this wave of crime
that was coming through it written house
we have a city engulfed in rioting
looting an arson the police are doing
nothing the citizenry says we got to
step up and do something to protect
ourselves to protect our city kyle goes
there as one of that group offering
medical services gets attacked kills
charged with murder and the risk is
because the state failed with arbory we
have a community that again is being
ravaged by crime this was once a little
dream community sleepy dream community
the house under construction was that
guy's dream house that he'd always
wanted to build there and now the
community literally was calling 911
day for three months that's how there
were there were neighbors in that
community single mothers with children
who would not let their children play
outside
because of their fear of the crime in
their community and they'd call the cops
the cops would show up the bad guys were
always gone so the community says yeah
everybody in that community was buying
guns installing security cameras um
joining doing neighborhood watch kind
sharing facebook messages and next door
messages with each other right next to
fletc by the way right okay
so the citizenry said listen no one's
helping us and we're living in fear so
we have to help ourselves and then we
have this encounter with arbor he dies
and they're going to jail for the rest
of their lives now so the chaos that's
created in these communities by crimes
and the failure of the state to provide
security is there any more fundamental
responsibility of the state than that
and the idea that you cannot protect
your community because the state has
taken responsibility but failed to
provide the security you can do it if
you want but if push comes to shove they
will prosecute you and put you in jail
for the rest of your polish the police
this is my this is my issue when when
people go and say well you know written
house should never been there written
how she's never been there so when
people say that to me i i i've said this
before but i haven't said it here
i say you know what you're right but at
the same time none of them should have
been there the rioters shouldn't have
been there the mob shouldn't have been
there the police should have the police
should have been there or in this case
the national guard when i remember in
jury selection i know you covered this
as well
that there were people who came up and
said things like
we keep in mind this was night three the
the car source had already been burned
once right this was knight three and by
the way he was asked to be there those
car source guys obviously asked for them
to be there don't even there's a video
of them there it's not even worth
talking about it's not even worth hard
they just literally just look at their
testimony they're obviously lying you
know they they clearly asked me to be
there we have all the evidence right so
there were people saying during jury
selection i was so scared that i took my
kids and we got out of town for the week
you had other people saying i couldn't
afford to get my kids out of town so we
went to the local church and i was there
sleeping with my children inside the
church because i thought that that
wouldn't get hit that it wouldn't get
burned i was in kenosha two weeks after
this happened a lot of kenosha by the
way is still bored still to this day
boarded up with these stars
rejected
uh
i'd have to go back and actually look at
this yeah there were so many a lot were
rejected a lot some got on but i
remember seeing on
the plywood that they'd put up they'd
say
live animals inside do not burn
i mean imagine having to write that up
on your town you have a situation this
is a this is a primal kind of situation
right you have marauders that are coming
out from from from chicago milwaukee
crossing state lines i mean this is like
the middle ages where this ravaging
horde would come out of the plane yeah
and burn your city so the village
village is it's anarcho-tyranny the
village is under attack
they're getting burned people are
freaking out they don't know they don't
know what's going to happen and i'll say
something else where all the people say
well he shouldn't have been there they
shouldn't have been there they shouldn't
have done this
all right i get it that's that's one
position to take and frankly it's a
position i would advocate because i
don't claim to have any particular
degree of bravery if i had an adult son
or a teenage son i wouldn't tell him to
get engaged in these events but people
need to keep in mind the unexpected
consequences of making that your
personal politic policy decision and one
of those consequences is what not a
month ago we had a woman raped on a
subway car in front of a bunch of people
and then everyone says nobody did
anything why didn't anybody do anything
you know what they would have impressed
because george zimmerman kyle written if
they had done something and found
themselves in a fight and killed that
guy
they get charged for more this is what
happens in china this is exactly what i
when i was in china there was a
situation where i was in kfc of all
places and um i'll tell the short
version of the story guy starts beating
his girlfriend on the other side of the
room starts just just smacking her slams
her head into the table um throws a soda
in her face and just starts just
walloping her right there you know a
couple of teenagers and he's sitting
with his friends there's people around
there's employees around i'm back i was
actually meeting my chinese tutor we
were studying uh practicing mandarin
and i'm thinking well surely the
employees will get involved and break
this up doesn't happen uh he keeps
hitting her
surely the customers will get involved
the men that are sitting around will do
something no
um so i got up and i got him and i
removed him from the kfc
and i remember afterwards and my mentor
i was still learning mandarin but i
heard people saying you know
why are you getting involved that's not
your problem we shouldn't need a wendy
not your problem right
and i i was i was freaked out afterwards
because i'm sitting there thinking this
is what almost 15 years ago but
at that point this was prior to you know
zimmerman and and written house and all
these things and i i it didn't even
enter into my mind that something like
that could happen in the united states
and nobody would do anything and i'm a
guy who's from the philadelphia area
right near where this happened now fast
forward right it's the same thing
because nobody wants to get on the radar
of the states one of one of my most
viewed videos is actually really old and
it periodically pops up in the analytics
on my uh i think on my tim cass channel
and it's men are no longer helping women
and children
it's a story i read where this woman
says
she was at a shopping center and she saw
a little kid crying with no parents
and she saw a man walking towards the
kids stop in his tracks look around turn
around and start walking quickly the
other way
someone ran up to the kid and said
what's wrong where's her parents they
found the mom and she and the journalist
the reporter who was watching it happen
ran up to the guy who turned around and
walked away she said i needed to
understand why he saw a crying child and
didn't do anything to help yeah and he
said are you kidding they'd call me a
predator and they'd accuse me of
kidnapping
so there are stories like this there was
a story in new york where a woman was
being punched on the subway and no one
would help
this this woman was attacked said that
there were men all around just watching
it happen and no no one would help her
and now fast forward to today with that
story of the woman on the subway getting
getting raped
while everybody watched no one did
anything and it's for exactly these
reasons anarcho-tyranny you are if you
if if you see a child crying and you go
up and say let me help you
good luck there are stories that i read
about there was a dad with his like
five-year-old daughter and they're at a
they're at a walmart and as they're
walking out someone called the cops
saying there's a strange man with a
child and the cops came and detained him
and questioned him and separated the kid
put her in the car i started asking her
a bunch of questions and he's like
that's my daughter and they're like
we're asking the questions here and of
course a five-year-old has no id and
then finally they determined okay well
it seems to be correct i go around with
his own daughter all the time
he doesn't have an aid he doesn't have
you're you sit him down he's not gonna
be able to answer any questions but by
the way prove that's your kid
looks like me you know yeah what might a
five-year-old say in all innocence okay
that would be interesting misinterpreted
by law enforcement what if you what if
you're playing cops and robbers with
your kid earlier in the day
and then the kid says that's that's he
was he's the bad man and you know he was
he's bad bad bad bad chasing chasing me
what if you're acting what if you're
lifting your kid out of his car seat and
you accidentally hurt his finger or
something and he's crying and then
somebody walks up and says what's going
on and he points at you and says he hurt
me yep yep right
hey my office is going to kill me if i
don't plug my book with that okay well i
mean it's been sitting behind you the
whole time but people people that book
behind me and this one on my hands sells
on amazon for 25 that's the normal price
for all you tim pool listeners we're
making this book available for free zero
dollars for the book whoa we do ask that
you pay this it's a physical book it's
not a pdf or something so it has to be
shipped we do ask you to pay the
shipping and handling but the book
itself is free normally 25 plain english
explanation of self-defense law how it
actually works and you can get that at
law of self defense dot com slash tim
cast cool cool all right folks grab it
grab only good for today by the way that
discount wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait you didn't
say your line you got to say this is
such a good time and i quote it like
every day now you got to see the line
well if you carry a gun like i carry a
gun so you're hard to kill i carry again
so i'm hard to kill my family is hard to
kill then you also owe it to your family
to make sure you know the law so you're
hard to convict boom i saw the mug and
it does sound a little dark like hard to
convict as if like but i think the fair
way to put it is know the law so you
stay within it stay within it absolutely
that's and that's the point right no
know the law no know your bounds know
your law and because you might be so
worried about not knowing the law that
you might be up at night and not be able
to sleep well yeah what would you do
what let me ask you a question oh no no
no i think i asked you i was winding up
i'll come back let me talk
i think i asked you this last time
you're on the show
let's say um
somebody is breaking into my house right
or actually how about this uh i know it
might depend on jurisdiction but let's
say someone is entering my property and
well it makes a difference you mean your
land or your home okay and and i have
big we have two big no trespassing signs
you know it's like be warned and so you
have to cross two of them so you know
you're trespassing in some states i
believe west virginia you actually have
grounds to use force like lethal force
if someone's entering not a lethal force
in west virginia no never really nowhere
no
uh not first not for what we would call
simple trespass in other words trespass
that's not clearly for other criminal
purposes you know trespass for purposes
of stealing property is becomes burglary
so that would be different but someone
just walks on your land it's a simple
trust you can use force to remove a
trespasser but only non-deadly force the
risk you run into of course is
non-deadly force can quickly escalate
into a deadly force situation
say you try to you grab them by the arm
and try to walk them off your property
they come up with a knife and now you
pull your gun you shoot them the
question is going to be well why'd you
really shoot him where's the knife we
don't have the knife in evidence we
think you shot him just because he was
trespassing on your land and that would
be justified so
what i want to get to is
you know tasers exist less lethals exist
is there a circumstance where less
lethals can be more uh legally
treacherous than actual lethal force
it would it would be hard to imagine how
that would be now there's there's
degrees of less lethal so for example
you can push someone off your property
or i guess you could tase them if
they're on your property but tasing is a
much
higher degree of force than simply
shoving somebody it's still non-deadly
but you have to be careful to maintain
proportionality within that non-deadly
bucket it's not
just because you can use some non-deadly
force doesn't mean you contain somebody
this is this is you know the reason i
ask is like for the average person they
don't have this training they don't know
the i mean that's great
yeah yeah but you know i remember
looking at the the what was it the
continuum of force in the chauvin trial
like a regular person's not going to
know and if somebody is coming on their
property and let me ask you this if a
guy enters your property he's got his
hand in his in his jacket as he's
walking up and he's looking at you and
then he goes to pull his hand out really
quick and then you shoot him what do you
think would happen to you
it would depend upon the local
jurisdiction so that's going to be a
judgment call by the prosecutor how do
you prove he was actually going to do
that
it turns out he had nothing in his hands
in theory you don't have to prove
anything the state has to prove
everything and they have to disprove
your claim beyond a reasonable doubt but
you know the challenge is if someone you
know
so here's where people get in trouble is
people normal law-abiding people i'm
talking most claims of self-defense are
nonsense they're bad guys their lawyers
just raising the claim of self-defense
i'm not talking about those i'm talking
about good guy
cases of self-defense where people tend
to get into trouble is not on the
extreme ends of the use of force
continuum right when when there's no
threat we don't do anything we just go
about our day if someone's jumping at us
with that giant sword you have hanging
on the wall over there well that's not a
complicated legal analysis well that's
that's the master sword from the legend
of zelda i mean yeah someone's jumping
at you with that you're done i mean
if someone had a real
if you're a ghost you can fire
whatever it can do it's not a
complicated legal analysis that's
clearly a deadly force threat it's
eminent etc you just you pull your
pistol you take care of that problem
that's not where people get in trouble
they get in trouble in between those two
extremes what i call the zone of
ambiguity where it's not clear what's
happening is it a deadly threat are we
sure is something else happening is
there do i have other options and unless
people have thought that through ahead
of time and developed learned techniques
to kind of to strip away the ambiguity
so like in that scenario
it's very common a common scenario i get
from women is hey i'm walking in a
parking garage late at night there's
some guy like walking behind me he
hasn't done anything yet but there's
something about him it's really scaring
me i know i can't just turn around and
shoot him because he hasn't done
anything yet i don't know what to do
well what you can do is turn around and
challenge that guy stay the f away from
me because if he's a normal guy just
walk into his car too what's he going to
do oh [ __ ] sorry didn't mean to scare
you if he keeps coming well you've
stripped away ambiguity right you've
clarified the situation and now his
conduct in the face of your verbal
commands to stay back is conduct
consistent with someone who means you
harm this is like guys who have no um
you know no uh hand-hand combat training
or have never done any mixed martial
arts or anything and they say oh i'm
just going to take that guy and that
street fight i just
i just see white man and i'm just gonna
go i'm gonna go all in right and it's
like you haven't taken any time to
actually train yourself to understand
what it's like to be in physical combat
with somebody to having you know or you
know a guy who has a gun that doesn't go
to the range or doesn't you know even
dry fire practice uh aiming or any of
this stuff i'm just gonna shoot kill man
no you're not they have these things
i love those people though because don't
you love this i have a very costly
german motorcycle habit and
those people pay for it my friend and i
had this idea a decade ago they have
these you know you ever see those ab
crunch belts
where it you you put the jet the
conductive gel on it yeah you put
conductive gel on it you wrap it around
your waist turn it on oh it like shocks
you yeah yeah but it doesn't shock you
it's uh i forgot i think it's like what
is it like high voltage low amps or
something like a low body so there's no
pain your muscles just contract twist
but so we used to play with it and like
we put on our faces and our faces just
like lock up and we would put it on our
arms and your arm would just be isn't
this wasn't this a johnny knoxville
thing i don't know i don't know no they
did with a taser i'm pretty sure i used
to put it on
so my friends and i my friend and i had
an idea to make gloves you used to
an yeah that you could make gloves that
you would turn on and if you grab
someone's arm you'd essentially disable
their ability to move their arm which
was you know and we actually talked with
a very big company who initially got
really excited for the the idea of a
crazy science project and then when the
uh like this these are the sales like in
sponsorship guys big big company that
makes gloves and then when they're like
head of legal found out they were
talking about making
muscle disabling and we were like
there's no pain no pain at all you if
you grab them their arms will just be
unable to move and they won't feel any
pain i mean they'll be scared and they
were like we will not sponsor this
project but i thought that was an
interesting idea i wonder why it doesn't
exist you know
well probably just because it's
unreliable i mean self-defense tools are
you wearing gloves you're wearing gloves
you know what do you what what what are
gloves for you power source yes no
no no not even tasers do what like
9-volt batteries oh yeah yeah you got a
little lithium-ion thing right
if it's a self-defense tool it's an
immersion it's like a parachute it has
to work if you're going to rely on it
and it's just an unproven i mean well
tasers suck i'm sorry they suck i would
not recommend them for civilian use um
they when they work right they work
amazingly well but there are so many
circumstances that keep them from
working right and if the suspect knows
he's going to get tased just him like
holding his shirt out away from his body
is a shield against the taser they're
not hard to defeat well so when police
use them properly you'll have one cop
with a taser and a cop right next to him
with a gun in case the taser is
ineffective when you're a civilian
you don't have that option you don't
have a second person with you with a gun
i think the glove thing is a good idea
because if they don't turn on they're
just gloves yeah but then they're not
working to defend you well
having no gloves you have nothing to
defend you no i love it
that's right i carry pepper spray for
example i carry a gun every day i also
carry pepper spray that's what i'm
saying you can carry those too but i
just i just think the idea of being able
to like you know someone is going to
attack you and you can grab them and
they can't move you can make it the
whole sleeve so you give them a bear hug
or or
any at any point if they touch you they
get you know their hand gets stuck yeah
what have you made like what have you
made like uh like a one you could throw
kind of almost like but it's like sticky
so that you throw it and then
i mean that's a good idea
because why would i want to be so close
that i have to touch somebody that they
could you know presumably do something
to me anything doesn't work whatever i'm
just throwing them i don't like it i
don't like contact weapons for
self-defense i like to maintain distance
yeah so here's an idea here here's an
all that what if we created some kind of
like um dense expanding sticky foam of
some sort and we could take the
cartridges and just put them on your
wrists and you can trigger it with a
little uh trigger so when you push your
fingers it will blast them with some
kind of sticky substance you know who
would love that
police departments and marvel yeah
[Laughter]
could you imagine if cops actually had
web shooters yeah and they like when
they fire a net of web it would be funny
because the whole the whole left is like
a holyoke subsidiary of disney now so
they would right so they wouldn't know
they wouldn't know how to be against it
if the cops were like yeah we're gonna
have these uh
yeah we're gonna have these uh these
these we're gonna come web packs and
they'll go right on your right on the
inside of your forearm there and you
just shoot them out at the crook and you
can get them off and then you have a lot
fewer riots
here's what you do
replace all police uniforms with
hogwarts uh uniforms
so all the police are running around and
instead of baton they're all equipped
with wands then it's like a wand but
they'll have their guns and everything
underneath their robes the goal is when
the riots happen they show up dressed
like harry potter characters and accuse
the writers of being death eaters i love
it right then the riots stop because
they're like get the death eaters right
and then and then afterwards you know
you have like it's like you don't call
it the um you know you don't call it the
community this should be the third hour
by the way
you don't usually have like the you know
the pr officer comes out the press
relations officer comes up but that'll
just be a professor right and the
professor comes out and it'll be a guy
in dumbledore
with with british accent and everything
the writers
were working
[Music]
he did a bit where it was like he says
rosenbaum is kind of like voldemort and
leftist is like
and there's a picture he has a picture
of cod written as harry potter and the
guy's like i can't believe that worked
all right let's go we're gonna go to
super chats if you haven't already smash
the like button subscribe to the channel
we're gonna have a members only segment
coming up at around 11 or so p.m
so um we're going to read some of those
super chats starting now
all right let's see
all right
darth crypto says i'm here live for this
hey
darth crypto yeah shout out to darth
crypto by the way he sent me some some
fantastic videos yeah while i was uh
covering the retin house trial it really
affected my legal analysis of the case
guy did absolutely fantastic work on the
fly he could easily do he even did a
great video that was um sort of a
preview of what bingers you know closing
was going to be and he got it very very
good yeah he got it yes you know right
and it was all about provocation and he
nailed it he just told me he says my
boy's representing let's talk written
house baby i'm still going for bingo
enco and i'm just getting warmed up hmm
nice yeah we we we did have some uh um
i don't know if it's public information
bingo and lunchbox
lunchbox by the way there's some
information about dominic black's case i
don't know if we're allowed to publicly
release it i don't know if it was
mentioned was it i don't i don't think
so i think it was behind the scenes but
suffice it to say bingo i don't believe
is done with uh written house or uh he's
going for dominick black on the gun
charges but i think he's desperately
trying to get back at written house
because i think um
the gun charge was dismissed right
yes the other charges were dismissed
on kyle not on
on dominic the judge said that case is
still up count six is dismissed on the
all other charges he was acquitted on so
i guess the charge is not coming back
against kyle
that's that's not going to happen you
don't think it's possible
i don't trust binger it's not realistic
basically the judge ruled as a matter of
law it doesn't apply
so you you don't get to just go shopping
for a different judge but here's my
question dominic black dominic's black
black's case they actually get another
judge to say oh yeah that's a misreading
of the world it's two different statutes
they're they're not charged under the
same statute
but here's my question about that two
different things so the statute they
charge kyle with simply is inapplicable
to his circumstances it's a i've done a
lot of analysis on this it's too late to
get into but that statute is a
completely different statute than
dominic black is charged under so the
fact that kyle's was dismissed has
nothing to do with blacks and blacks has
nothing to do with kyle's that being
said
the killings do apply it you know it
might i mean if our blacks defense
lawyer because i would start arguing
that look the statute is a gun that was
used in a death right so giving a gun to
a minor and a death results yes and it's
intended of course to prevent giving
guns to young gang members who then go
kill people or get killed themselves and
obviously nobody wants that but in those
cases what the what the statutes
intended to prevent is unlawful debts
and that didn't happen here this gun was
used
in a justified manner
these deaths were lawful determined
in a court of law
so i would argue that
this statute does not apply to the
specific circumstances of dominic black
because the gun he provided was not used
to commit an unlawful kill dominic black
already testified he didn't provide a
gun
[Music]
maybe he should have told the truth
we'll see stood up for his friend and
not tried to weasel his way out of
charges all the testimony around the
whole gun thing was very was very shaky
because bingo was trying to make
different points at different times and
therefore
was testifying
well he did a lot of that yeah it felt
like finger was testifying and then just
kind of pushing someone into a corner
and be like that's what happened right
that was that was a very funny part
he was talking about is that fair is
that fair yeah the ammo yeah he was
asking uh kyle about the ammo so uh you
know are you aware that you know that
full metal jacket is different than
hollow point kyle's like i don't really
know that much about ammo
well let me explain it to you and you
said he was wrong and the judge comes
down
he said he said he said
explode
and then explode kyle's face he goes
he's like what would you use it for deer
hunting and kyle's like
i don't think anyone would use hollow
point for deer but that's not true no
it's not true
too i mean
i don't have i have a polymer tip 450
right bushmaster so it's effectively uh
hollow points right right it's for deer
hunting yep you know well it's polymer
sure but that's
but it's effectively a hollow point you
know it's a soft it's a popular tip so
that it functions the same way you use a
hollow point for deer hunting because
you want you want the bullet to expand
and dump as much energy into the the
prey animals as possible right uh you
wouldn't use filament full metal jacket
literally punches a pencil size hole
right through and maybe it's a it's an
injury that will prove mortal some days
later i mean who knows but that's not
what you want when you're hunting you
want the animal to be stopped humanely
right there i think the defense
mentioned this they said in some cases
the you know the prosecution will say
you used hollow points you were trying
to kill and now he's saying use full
metal jacket see that proves it it's
never the right bullet for the
prosecutor
ever whichever one he said it was the
other one that was right right
all right let's read some more we got
cristiano it says for luke and it's a
puking emoji
archangel says no luke we puke ladies
and gentlemen give him a break luke has
a family
and it's thanksgiving tomorrow so he
needs to drive it's tomorrow right
thanks tomorrow yeah yeah okay good all
day uh we're we're doing our family
thanksgiving over the weekend but we're
gonna have like a company thanksgiving
for those that aren't you know so we're
not going to be here tomorrow or friday
and then i'm not the holidays man forced
days off you can't really dare you i
i've tried to work through them it
doesn't work i work
you got to accept yeah but for like the
work we do people are eating dinner
they're not watching the show
no one's reporting anything everyone
even criminals are spending time with
grandma so crimes aren't being committed
and we just this was this was the wire
it was uh you know the sunday morning
truce yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah you know
about the christmas uh truce
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah world war ii one
yeah one yeah amazing the trenches
soccer game they all came out and said
it's christmas we're not gonna fight and
and then they're like all right
christmas is over i'll be over there
shooting at you they still didn't want
to fight but then the french commanders
were like you have to fight or we'll
kill you
and so the troops were like well
rather than get shot by our commanding
officers we'll we'll charge them and
then the mustard gas came back on yeah
that was nasty
martin edgar says i see your 35 year old
skating and raise you 54 year old seven
year army with daily runs four times per
year 12 mile road marches 23 years as a
city carrier walking route and my
response is have you gotten your ageless
moment
yeah i was gonna say he's teeing you up
right there right right
stronger bones in life.com that's right
medic knight
tim asks jack if he believes biden will
get the u.s into a war with iran
remember biden is a war hawk ask him if
thanks ron paul was right on everything
dems of the party of war
uh
i'm still trying to find the issue where
ron paul was wrong
you know
um and so yeah and i'd say pretty much
everything
pretty much everything ron paul was
right there there's some things i could
i could you know think of whereas i'm
more conservative than a libertarian on
but um
as far as war with iran i certainly
think he has people around him that want
to go to war he's sending
um
right now iran doesn't seem to be the
main target it seems to be that uh
because you remember the obama people
that were around him were the ones that
were trying to pay off iran right they
didn't they want to go to war they were
trying these weren't the warhawks yeah
sorry right right right they were you
know continually paying off this was the
pallets of cash people yeah um that
being said russia i would say is
probably more the one that they want to
provoke uh a war with they're sending
special forces i'm sorry advisers to
ukraine right now and then china um
they're of course just going to
capitulate to
right or perhaps already have
all right seth boos says here's one for
poso the last member segment you did you
talked about sabaton top three albums
please go oh yeah
so with sabaton
um i love the latest uh great war world
war one i've burned a hole in that i
mean i don't listen to cds anymore but i
still like that phrase burned a hole in
it um i love the one on last stanz and i
also have this um
this uh mix that i basically got that
it's it was sort of like an online
playlist that people made of the
greatest hits that i really like
and that's the last uh live album too
but real quick on sabotan i am trying
very hard and i'd like to enlist
everyone out there if you don't know who
sabaton is they're like a swedish um
hard rock band that does historical
references and all of their music to uh
actual warfare
and uh specific you know real-life
battles of course they sing a lot about
poland uh and poland they're extremely
extremely well uh well-respected and um
i want to troll them into making an
album about the american revolutionary
war i mean think about a metal song to
paul revere like it writes itself it
does come on sabaton you can do this
question for andrew what's worse for
self-defense a gun or using a knife
oh i'm not sure what wurst means but uh
when we talk about the dependency of
force i mean the use of force law
doesn't really care about the means of
force so there's non-deadly force and
there's deadly force once you're in the
deadly force bucket it's all the same so
a gun is not more deadly force than a
knife or more deadly force than a
baseball bat to the head if it's likely
to kill or cause serious bodily injury
it's deadly force it's all the same it's
a homogenous bucket you're within 10 20
feet you know i'll i might i might take
the knife
well knives are horrible i would much
rather get shot than than yeah
i've watched the police training videos
yeah i watched the mythbusters episode
i've been in those trainings these these
uh these uh and i've done the heat
training too and they always say like
you know somebody's coming out coming at
you with a knife run run run get out
right just don't be there but these
people i mean the only advantage of a
gun really is the gun you can use at a
distance before the enemy's on you but
if he's got a knife and he can grab you
it's going to be a real bad day let's be
honest
a gun can use at a distance
how likely is the average person to hit
their target if they're beyond 21 well
not not not very likely and especially
with the handgun yeah and who's the the
dude from mythbusters they're both out
of weight i mean they're both out of
shape and overweight
and wanna got one of the guys was able
to close 21 feet in like a second and a
half yeah like two seconds that's the
normal standard yeah and so uh
i think jamie i don't know the other
game he couldn't even get the gun out of
the holster it was a laser he would get
it out and point it and click and see if
he could get him he couldn't each time
the knife
it was a foam knife that tapped his feet
you're not going to you're not going to
get the gun out and get center mass hits
unless you train and practice and
practice and practice and practice to do
that i mean i shot competitively most of
my adult life i can clear the gun for my
whole story center mass targets in under
a second wow but i worked damn hard 20
years yeah
for the defense to ha of the rittenhouse
case plus you have to write holster
was closing the gap because he would not
have made the hit running right and from
at least
you know seven feet he would have been
able to do it where where was that
defense expert yeah and by the way i
just want i just want to point out for
people who are sitting right here yeah
she should have been there for people
who may not know kyle rittenhouse had
fired that ar rifle once one time before
in his life dude he did great when he
was out in that street and he made
he everybody he shot was someone
attacking him except for jump kick man
which is very difficult situation
getting knocked on your butt and trying
to hit somebody who's jumping on top of
you
those two misses i'll i'll forgive him
everything else was a solid hit and i
think it's really a testament to the
utility of that ar platform for
self-defense this is the purpose it's so
easy to use effectively even in novice
hands it's an amazing i mean think of it
they're designed for 17 18 year old e1
privates right that are put into
you know a combat situation but this was
not i we got to be careful here he has a
2 2 3 a uh i was an m p 15.
it's not a weapon of war
no it's a two-two-three it's a sporting
rifle yeah they don't give two to three
to to do they do they oh it's the same
caliber it's it's in the military yeah
it's functionally the same but they get
to be an m4 but
select fire556 is a different weapon
well two two three is the caliber of the
round right it's equivalent to the
metric 5.56 so the round being fired is
effectively the same from from both guns
his is
select fire it's not sorry it's not a
fully automatic weapon the military is a
selection it's
extremely similar well my my point is
there's a big difference between being
an air fifteen
sure but it's not so other than that but
you don't train to fire on if you're
firing full auto in you're having a bad
day already
we have to be very careful when we talk
about weapons used for war because this
was not it no no no no it was certainly
not designed but but i that i'm talking
about the original design of the ar-15
because it was originally designed for
the military for department of end to
use except that the original design
always had selective fire and that's the
one reason that you see the forward
assist that's on it because because
originally the designer didn't want that
but the military said no we have
soldiers and this these are people at
the time that had served in world war ii
and they said look we've been in so many
situations where the round doesn't
chamber something goes wrong we want
that forward assist and i believe that
when on that video where you do see kyle
at one point and this is the
what came in with gage grosskroots uh
where where gage claims falsely that
kyle is uh is you know uh recharging the
handle that's a very deliberate and it's
a big motion definite motion that you
would see on camera
but you can tell that he does kind of
move his hand down he tilts the gun
towards him a little bit
and i believe what he's doing is he's
slamming that forward assist interesting
so the real hydro says a man got life in
prison for recording something if it
wasn't for his recording the da wouldn't
have anything this country is doomed
uh
based on the story that i read that
neighbor who was just following and
filming he's getting charged with fell
he got convicted a felony murder for
that well they're they're claiming he in
effect that he attacked right arbory
with his truck he committed assault with
the truck which is a deadly force attack
aggravated assault it's a felony and
then arbory died as a con now i would
suggest there's a real causation problem
there because there's no evidence he hit
arbor with the truck and there's no
evidence the truck literally caused
arbory's death right he didn't run him
over with the truck
arbory didn't jump off a cliff to avoid
the truck uh but nevertheless that's the
basis so once you have the felony of
aggravated assault and the the later
death uh well then it's the death is
felony murder was he rep did they all
have the same defense or do you know
that
every defendant had their had two
lawyers of their own okay do they
because whose decision was it to try it
all together do they try to separate
that at all
you know i don't know that like the last
day of the trial
o'brien tried to sever was what the as a
legal term sever himself from the other
defenders i would imagine
that yeah
from the start the judge didn't allow it
so they chose to do a joint trial
i don't know if they had an option and
that's a criminal procedure thing that
would be so local you'd have to ask an
attorney the prosecutor naturally wants
to try it because i imagine the
prosecutor want that to be all together
yeah because then then
everybody everyone seems responsible all
the evidence is it appears to be against
every defendant right because of course
their theory is well this was a
coordinated act this you guys planned
this in advance or at least you had
something yeah
anytime a prosecutor can try a bunch of
people together they'll do that every
time yeah of course because then you
know if you if you had three defendants
and really a third of the evidence was
against each one what it looks like in
court is that 100 of the evidence is
against all three because then that
right
man and then you get three convictions
out of one right
resta says do you think the media is
light reporting on waukesha is because
they are they are gun shy from written
house lawsuits coming their way i think
they're terrified of waukesha i think
they're terrified i think it's political
of that narrative yeah i think it's
political i think that this is a
situation again the same way that kyle
rittenhouse walked because of
independent media it's the same
situation that now where independent
media is one of the most important
things to the survival of this country
and the survival of freedom in this
country because it is the last bastion
shows like this shows like you know we
all have podcasts and everything that we
do i'm not trying to do a hard pitch
here um that
you are not going to get the truth
anymore from corporate media or regime
media as you want to call it it's all
it's all live all the way down has been
ever since a zimmerman case everything
they're writing about these cases is
disinformation i will say that people
who think kyle's going to get a lot of
money suing people i think they're
that's a pipe dream that's not going
really why i don't think the courts will
be favorable to him because anything
that was in the criminal indictment
he's not going to be able to sue over
because the courts have said if it's in
a criminal indictment then calling him a
murderer stuff like that that's people
are allowed to make that information
what about biden though
what about biden that fat progressive
guy just tweeted out like literally the
other day that got right now's crossed
state lines robert reich yeah with an
illegal which limbo used to say robert
a false statement of fact jerk right
right and i i i suppose it challenges
damages that's the challenge right so
there's three problems one is the
criminal indictment stuff forget it you
can't see over that people are allowed
to refer to that and infer that there's
some truth to it or it wouldn't have
been an indictment
and stuff like racism and white
supremacist the courts don't care about
they call that opinions
but even if you could get someone on a
deliberate statement of fact well
there's a couple more problems one is
that kyle was giving interviews not just
recently but in the past and the moment
you start giving interviews the courts
say well you made yourself a public
figure maybe you weren't when you got
attacked the first time but now that
you're giving media interviews you're
publishing my finger people are allowed
to talk about you
they have to show malice now if they
want to collect money i think but even
if you can do all of that
what are your damages because your
damages will be damaged to reputation
but all that other stuff the murder the
white supremacist the racist he has no
reputation left
what are the damages um uh for for the
uh alex jones case
because he said some conspiracy stuff
about san diego they claim i believe
they're coming in emotional distress oh
okay well it looks like they're going to
win
we don't know for sure the media is
lying about everything they're uh they
did rule alex jones in default because
they claimed the things he turned over
in the discovery weren't the total of
what they were actually asking for they
said we want x he says he gave them x
they say you're still missing key
documents so they ruled in default
apparently he has some time to respond
to not be in default but they're
reporting he lost already and he's been
found guilty none of that is true but
they're they're looking at well if
there's a default judgment it's a
judgment i mean what what i mean is what
damages does that family have because
alex jones said
i think i don't know anything about here
here's what i think but it's completely
different than nick sandman for example
who was not a criminal defendant so
there were no charges against him there
was no indictment uh he was not giving
interviews so he wasn't a public figure
he got a lot of money because he meets
the criteria for getting a lot of money
and and kyle rittenhouse really doesn't
well there's two things
first even if kyle rittenhouse loses
after suing the media he it's actually
not possible for kyle rittenhouse to
lose
his efforts against the mainstream press
when it comes to definite defamation
it's not possible because one of two
things will happen either the news
organizations will have to publicly
state that their standards don't include
reading uh the criminal indictments in
their investigations don't include
cursory investigations that they just
publish hearsay as fact or or opinion as
fact or scuttlebutt as you're saying
they'll have to argue that in court they
will have to publicly state in documents
it is a standard at cnn that we do not
do basic uh base research in any of our
stories because that would be the actual
mela standard but will the people who
watch cnn care about that
it's irrelevant it's still a victory
rachel maddow admitted this and she's
still getting you know a pay raise
having having uh uh
these organizations have to publicly
state this is bad for them across the
board it will it will it's not going to
be a million dollar paycheck but it is a
cultural to me to me i think that it's
even bigger than the media you have
joe biden who's our current president
ran and used this kid as a political
pawn lied about him lied about his
family called him a racist called him
and now they're trying to play this game
of oh i was referring to this shut up
that's not what you were talking about
you used him to gain the highest office
in the land falsely he should have his
campaign by the way they should sue the
campaign not him personally sue the
campaign and then go after them because
they don't have whatever kind of
immunity that the president oh that
would hurt re-election the campaign
because yes you would have to hurt
because biden well the white house is
telling people he's gonna run again but
privately that's not what he's telling
people the the other important thing is
that when it comes to damages i think
kyle's going to easily be able to argue
that
security name changes he's going to have
to move out of the state he's got to
protect his address now he already is
out of seat right he's going to do this
for the rest of his life but the other
side is going to say look he would have
had to have done that anyway we didn't
make that happen in any substantial way
that was already damaged he was
incurring from other
i th the the new york times ruled this
in uh uh i'm sorry the court's rule this
is new york times case supreme court
rules with veritas a different state i
understand but they said to the new york
times because the new york times argued
their reputation is too damaged already
we couldn't damage it any further and
the judge basically said
just because other people are kicking
them doesn't mean you are clear of your
responsibilities for kicking them well
listen i hope kyle gets hundreds of
millions of dollars that would be
absolutely awesome but i'm just telling
cautioning people i think a lot of
people look at this and they just assume
that he's obviously got a downhill fight
in this and i'm i think it's more
complicated than that i think it's more
i think a lot of people a lot of people
think sandman got 250 million dollars
from cnn which is absolutely not true by
any reasonable assessment or legal
assessment he got a settlement which
means they may have paid him 25 grand
some people said it was probably a
nuisance fee cnn said how much do you
want to go away and stop bothering us
and they said that we don't know right i
mean because right i mean it's a
settlement it wasn't 250 million one
thing one thing i should say while we're
talking about this that if you do
believe that kyle deserves this stuff
you go to free kyle usa
and that's where you can actually
contribute and help the fight so kyle
who obviously deserves a victory in all
this it's free kyle usa believe its.org
that you go to that's where you
contribute to help his fight we have
this uh from one free man he says i own
a construction company and i've had over
a hundred
and had over hundreds of thousands
stolen stop emboldening criminals
when it comes to
arbory walking in that home under
construction people need to understand
is that there's copper there's copper
steel there's wood i mean woods right
now yeah let me let me tell you we're
putting up a new deck we opened by
bought lumber i was shocked oh it's
worse we talked about it but i was still
shocked we're setting up uh uh so so
yeah i just saw you doing the we're
doing construction
they said hey we're having
trouble with the hvac stuff because we
need to we need to reposition it and
that means we need a lot of hvac stuff
we can't get because of the supply
crunch
so if you have a construction site and
you're putting up a new building and
someone goes in there and takes anything
that could completely destroy the entire
project
so having this dude coming in five times
sounds like casing
at best
or plundering you know i mean he's not
going to run off with you know a
thousand pounds worth of lumber but he's
looking for power tools or i used to
work as a mechanic and we used to have
guys walk in the garage all the time
just off the street and just grab a
power tool and and run out with it
she'll just go up on it yeah so that's
probably what was happening but in any
case people should be clear under
georgia law felony burglary doesn't
require you actually take anything it
just requires you entered the property
with the intent to take something how
would they know
well you know intent how do you always
know intent we can't read people's minds
we infer intent from the circumstances
so he walks into this building he's
looking around at stuff and then he it's
been several times if you're in someone
else's property in the middle of the
night you can reasonably infer you're
there for an unlawful purpose there's no
lawful reason so i actually had a
question that um that came in uh from my
dad and my brother who are watching and
they said you know given all this that
we're talking about and it goes to what
what tim was asking you know what does
that mean for a neighborhood watch
operating in 2021 you know i get this
question a lot because i have people
what do you do i have people contact me
say hey what if there's a riot or
something can we set up like a joint
defense group in our community right
where we'll all have our ars we'll stand
at the end of the street if you have a
car dealership for example right yeah
well this is the example first of all if
you have a formalized group where you've
all agreed to do this and someone ends
up getting killed by a member of your
group guarantee you the prosecutor is
going to call every conspiracy everyone
is going to be charged oh yeah
as an accessory
everyone's going to be charged with
michigan was a militia and they're going
to go to they're going to go to the
group individually they're going to say
hey we got aw 9 of you 10 of you right
part of this group you're all on
facebook all together right we know
you're all part of the group uh one of
you is going to jail for the rest of
your lives
what are the other of you willing to say
about that one person and we're not
telling you which person it'll be we'll
just see what you say maybe it'll be you
the only way for it not to be you is for
you to be helpful in our investigation
this is the classic prisoner's dilemma
worst idea
so the least liked guy in that group
gets screwed every other guy
every other guy in that group is going
to be dominic black on the witness stand
testifying winger kept trying to tie
kyle to the kenosha guard facebook page
he tried it for months and months and
they couldn't find any evidence and then
there was one point where and i'm
paraphrasing but he was in on one of
those one of the zoom earlier hearings
where he's trying to say well he
operated with other people who may have
been part of the and and it was
schroeder who was just like
you you can't we're not doing this right
we're not going so you give kyle another
judge you take away those videos he's in
a very different situation i i i don't
respond well to manipulation i i have
like an inverted uh response i suppose
you know people might assume the
prosecutor would be like we're going to
pressure you
if they actually came in were reasonable
he's the guy we flip on then yeah that's
right yeah then you're the guy
yeah easily
tim was the ring leader
because all those other guys they're
going to have you know their wife and
their kids and all this kind of stuff
they're going to say i i i can't afford
to go to prison the same way so if
someone's going to go down it's not
going to be me might as well be but this
is why you don't join these groups well
that's that's why i always caution
people people like dominic black you
know cowards and pathetic whiny little
losers will turn on you in two seconds
and then still claim to be friends with
you and then you know kyle will
apparently still be friends with him
because you know i think people are just
weak i mean in this in this arbor case
there was literally zero evidence that
there was any coordination between the
mcmichaels and between brian but that
didn't keep the prosecutor from arguing
accessory from arguing that brian was a
party to everything
so
what would you tell people but what
would you also just tell people that
really do care about their neighborhood
maybe not necessarily faced with one of
these situations but just in general
the prudent thing to do would be for
each person to be you know at the end of
their own driveway maybe sharing a cup
of coffee with an ar slung if they're
afraid an angry looting arsoning horde
is going to come down their street but
the moment they organize and even in an
informal way like we're a collective
group we're working cooperatively
if something bad happens they're all
except they're all parties to the
criminal offense well you know what i
would say and honestly even answer to my
dad's question is
you have a cell phone everybody's got
one of these things
these are so incredibly powerful look at
how every single one of these stories we
talked about from waukesha to kenosha to
georgia we know about it because of the
cell phone oh yeah listen there's a
reason i have security cameras all over
the outside of my house and it's not
just so i see stuff coming in and so if
something happens
i want that camera footage i mean it's
an interesting anecdote from the george
zimmerman trial they were they were
investigating him for this killing of
trayvon martin and his story sounded
like self-defense to everybody but they
try to trap him right they want to test
this story they want to test his
willingness to stick by that story of
self-defense so they came to him they
called him back into the police station
he went without a lawyer like he always
did i remember that yes and they sat him
down they said listen george we have a
real problem with your self-defense
story because uh
we found some surveillance video and we
know exactly what happened and you know
what george said thank god
because he knew he knew what happened he
knew that if they had video it was going
to be in his favor i want that video if
something happens outside my house that
being said if the cops overcome
thought the video was going to exonerate
them from the uh again i think the story
was that the community hated them and so
he was like here's the video i can only
say that that guy was described by his
own attorney in court as not the
smartest guy in the room
i don't i don't understand how sending
that out of prison which again show it
to a lawyer first he was he was nearly
in tears when they were reading the
verdict and i'm like this this dumb guy
driving a car filming something
gives out the footage to be like here's
what happened and now he's going to
prison
i don't this is why people say i will
not be involved
by the way another reason not to be part
of a group
one member of that group might be roddy
bryan
yeah
right might do something that basically
blows everything up you know when i was
a kid my dad would always be like if you
ever commit a crime do it by yourself
and it but it was it was not like a
literal it was it was a point about how
you know make sure when you're when
you're teaming up with people you don't
have idiots with you so that like you
didn't literally mean documentaries i've
got a lot of friends in law enforcement
they'll tell me that the hardest cases
they have to solve is where the bad guy
did it by himself and didn't say a word
to anybody
because that's how you break those cases
is when they they have they have uh
accessories from the crime someone who
will talk or they told someone and that
person well it's a lot of self defense
ends up being that way too it's right
you know it's
me
and i'm with a guy and it's late you
know i mean a lot of it is but a lot of
it's not i mean a lot of it is you know
in in people have a beef and it's in a
public environment and people the these
days everyone's got their camera as soon
as you know yeah
i mean prior yeah prior to always what
is what is james
what does james o'keefe say he always
acts as though there's a jury of 12
watching what he's doing yeah right it's
good
so when you're when you're out at a bar
and someone picks a fight with you
just
know the camera's watching and you need
to make sure that you are avoiding
active aggression you are initiating you
back away you put your hands up you
shake your head and you try and
de-escalate because the fight the fight
you a fight you can escape is the fight
you've won what matters is not what you
think you're doing what matters is how
your conduct will be perceived by other
people other people who may not have
your best interests at heart so you
almost have to role play yourself when
you're out in public assume you're
always on camera people are always
watching and how are they going to
perceive your conduct don't skate the
thin line of self-defense make sure you
are way way inside the thin line by the
way if you want to know where that line
is
law of self defense dot com
slash tim cast for a free copy of this
25. well now now i got to do it because
folks if you are worried about sleeping
soundly in your bed at night there we go
i'm worried if someone's keeping watch
for you now you might not be the one
who's drawn watch that night so if
you're sleeping make sure that you're
sleeping on a my pillow from
mypillow.com with promo code posa up to
65 off beat joe biden and beat bootage
with the supply chain shipping problems
beat the fact and by the way thank god
to the 35 what is it 37 of truckers who
are standing up to the vaccine mandate
god bless them give them a hand and give
them some business at mypillow.com
yeah get your get your your christmas
shipping and we're going to go over to
the member segment so don't forget to
smash the like button subscribe to this
channel go to timcast.com become a
member so we can have that um
substantially less family-friendly
members only show it's like you know wow
you're 18 and older man i don't know you
don't want your kids here that stuff we
swear all the time we talk about really
serious issues but if you want to hear
that stuff guest.com become a member you
can follow the show tim cast irl
basically on all platforms
we got banned from tick tock but hey and
you can follow me personally at tim cast
you guys want to mention your socials
sure law of selfdefense.com uh we also
just started the locals i'm new to that
but that would be law self
defense.locals.com brand new there's
like i don't know 30 supporters right
now but hopefully it'll be thousands in
the near future
i don't know tim if you've got any uh
much of an audience in in the uk um but
i'm actually gonna be over in speaking
in london on december 8th with the nigel
farage and european group of european
delegates that are coming we're talking
about free speech that's at the counter
conference and then i'm also going to be
speaking in phoenix with uh tucker
carlson charlie kirk kaylee mcnaney
candace owens
rand paul take a ton of you know
senators congressmen few people haven't
announced yet uh that's the turning
point usa america fest phoenix arizona
tim love to have you there if possible
we might try and figure something out
but it's tough yeah third week of
december out there in phoenix if you got
to be somewhere in uh in winter it might
as well be in phoenix true that
nice night good information thanks for
coming guys this was fast fascinating
fantastic and uh thanks for i have more
more questions about deep fakes and the
future of video as evidence let's talk
about indeed seriously seriously great
questions yes we'll we'll deep bevin
that oh i want to talk all about it a
lot to say
oh lydia oh yeah
thank you very much for coming and
educating us about the law that's kind
of one of my weak points so i really
appreciate all the conversation about
some of these details thank you guys
both uh jack and andrew happy to be here
you guys can follow me on twitter at
sourpatchlids we will see you all at
timcast.com in the member segment thanks
for hanging out bye guys
you